[Musique]
non
bonsoir à tous bonsoir à tout avec
mathieu belliard bonsoir monsieur
bonsoir laurence bonsoir à toutes et à
tous nous vous souhaitons donc la
bienvenue dans ce débat c'est news
europe 1 qui a pour thème demain quelle
france donc l europe nous sommes à 46
jours des élections européennes ce sera
le 26 mai nous sommes quasiment cinq
mois après le début du mouvement des
gilet jaune dans notre pays
quelle vision portée vous pour notre
pays au sein d'une europe divisée
les règles sont simples pour cette
soirée vous avez un temps de parole à
respecter vos chronomètre sont affichés
en permanence sur les côtés vous pouvez
gérer votre temps de parole nous
veillerons à ce que vous puissiez vous
exprimer vous interpeller aussi si vous
le souhaitez et puis vous qui nous
regardent et sur ses news et qui nous
écoutait sur europe 1 vous pouvez réagir
interagir sur twitter avec le hashtag
qfp eux quelle france dans quelle europe
et revivre aussi les moments forts de ce
débat sur l'application my canal une
émission spéciale en trois parties
d'abord l'urgence du pouvoir d'achat où
vont nos impôts lesquels baissé suivra
la crise de l'autorité en france comment
expliquer ces violences observée ces
derniers mois qu'est ce qui peut nous
réunir à nouveau
c'est la question que nous vous posons
et puis bien sûr la relance de l'europe
comment relancer et à combien vous
représentez ce soir un spectre large non
exhaustif mais un spectre représentatif
de la société française les français qui
sont face à vous veulent savoir ce qui
vous définit ce qui vous différencie ce
soir le tout sur un pied d'égalité alors
un tirage au sort a été réalisé avec vos
équipes avec les nôtres le hasard a
déterminé un ordre de première prise de
parole dans l'ordre tirés au sort
laurent wauquiez pour les républicains
stanislas guérini pour la république en
marche david cormand pour europe
ecologie les verts il ya nicolas dupont
aignan pour debout la france olivier
faure pour le parti socialiste marine le
pen pour le rassemblement national et
adrien à quatre mains ce pour la france
insoumise bonsoir à tous ce soir
soyez les bienvenus l'europe au coeur de
notre débat en fil rouge ce soir
comprenez bien que l'europe est au coeur
de toutes ces problématiques dont vous
débattre et et de l'union européenne il
est question ce soir en direct pour ce
conseil européen extraordinaire sur le
brésil
nous retrouverons isabelle ory
correspondants européens à bruxelles
experte de ces questions européennes
bonsoir isabelle et
tout à l'heure et on a commencé tout de
suite notre premier chapitre la
fiscalité et le pouvoir d'achat
[Musique]
la grogne était fiscale ces derniers
mois immense exaspération fiscal a dit
le premier ministre les français n'ont
pas tant réclamer des hausses de
salaires que des baisses d'impôts et
c'est aussi la problématique du
consentement à l'impôt qui est posée
avec cette crise cette question où va
notre argent alors avant de vous
entendre débattre quelques éléments de
réponse
tendez l'oreille il va y avoir quelques
chiffres quelques éléments de réponse
avec guillemette allard et anne-laure
jus mais en france on a les dépenses
publiques les plus élevés de l'union
européenne l'an dernier le taux de
prélèvements obligatoires s'est élevé à
48 5 4% du pib soit près de 1000 110
milliards d'euros
cela signifie que près de la moitié de
la richesse produite est prélevée par
l'état la sécurité sociale et les
collectivités locales pour financer les
dépenses publiques
parmi ces prélèvements il ya les
cotisations sociales et puis il ya les
impôts parmi les plus connus l'impôt sur
le revenu la tva et la csg
en 2018 le gouvernement à relever le
taux de la csg
résultat 25 8 milliards de plus dans les
caisses de l'état
une fois collectés comment répartir
l'argent prenons un billet de 100 euros
de dépenses publiques
le poste le plus importante concerne les
retraites plus d'un quart des recettes
ils sont consacrés soit un peu plus de
26 euros
viennent ensuite les dépenses liées à
l'assurance maladie
19 euros les dépenses liées à la famille
au chômage aux aides au logement et au
rsa représente l'équivalent de 12 euros
au total les dépenses de protection
sociale représente 57 euros soit plus de
la moitié des dépenses publiques en
france
autre enveloppe importante le budget de
l'éducation celui de la défense la
sécurité et la justice et celui des
administrations publiques
quant à la charge de la dette elle
représente l'équivalent de 3 euros 70 et
le climat dans tout ça c'est une
préoccupation majeure pour les
générations futures mais pas encore pour
les finances du pays sur notre billet de
100 euros de dépenses publiques
la transition énergétique ne représente
qu'un d'euros 60 soit à peine plus que
le prix d'un café au comptoir et la
première question est donc pour laurent
wauquiez vous proposer la baisse de
l'impôt sur le revenu est donné pour
cent pour tout le monde y compris pour
les pleurer oui d'abord une chose sur
laquelle je vais être très clair en
france conscience des questions là il
faut être très clair oui c'est ce qu'on
propose même pour les plus riches
et pourquoi est ce qu'on fait ça parce
qu'en france quand on dit on va taxer
uniquement les plus riches
à l'arrivée ça finit toujours de la même
manière les seuls qui paye ses les
classes moyennes votre reportage on
prêterait il ya trop d'impôts en france
trop d'impôts et c'est sans doute parce
que le gouvernement ne l'a pas compris
au début on s'est retrouvé dans cette
crise est une chose sur laquelle votre
reportage ne s'est pas attardé il ya une
deuxième injustice en france qui payent
l'impôt
ceux qui sont au milieu les classes
moyennes c'est là où est concentrée tout
l'impôt quand vous appartenait aux
classes moyennes
le gouvernement vous prend plus de 50
pour
de ce que vous gagnez ce qui est la
première injustice m'interroger en me
demandant pourquoi est ce qu'on propose
la baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu mais
précisément parce que c'est l'impôt qui
frappe les classes moyennes est ce qu'on
demande c'est une baisse simple 10% pour
tout le monde pourquoi le gouvernement a
proposé une baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu mais uniquement ciblées sur
certaines catégories en disant on va
baisser uniquement pour ceux qui sont
entre 1700 euros et 1800 euros
les seuils qui sont la spécialité de
notre pays vous êtes à 1750 c'est bon
vous êtes à 1900 c'est pas bon non il
faut baisser pour tout le monde et un
deuxième élément rapidement rapidement
dont personne ne parle
dont le premier ministre n'a pas parlé
lundi que vous n'avez pas évoqué c'est
la situation des retraités
je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez
madame ferrari mais des propos qui
étaient ceux du président de la
république pendant la campagne
présidentielle
je ne toucherai pas au pouvoir d'achat
des retraités
le résultat c'est qu'en deux ans les
retraités deux retraités sur trois ont
perdu du pouvoir d'achat en moyenne un
couple de retraités a perdu 400 euros
m'interroger sur nos propositions
notre deuxième proposition c'est qu'il
faut revaloriser au minimum de
l'inflation toutes les retraites et
retraite
dans un pays comme le nôtre et 6 et man
va évoquer précisément je rappelle à nos
auditeurs à nos téléspectateurs que vous
avez un oeil sur votre chronomètre
faites attention vous le gérer comme
vous l'entendez vous connaissez
évidemment la règle du jeu vous
précisément sur les retraites stanislas
guérini est ce qu'il faut un geste
fiscal pour les retraités
d'abord nous avons déjà fait un geste
puisque vous avez rappelé nous avons
augmenté la csg pour baisser les charges
qui pesaient sur le travail mais
l'augmentation de la csg c'est
merveilleux marine au sort des retraités
nous sommes revenus en décembre dernier
sur cette décision et d'ailleurs d'ici
quelques mois un grand nombre de
retraités non recevoir un chèque pour
compenser l'augmentation de ses jets
qu'ils avaient peur mais a retiré qu'est
ce qu'ont exprimé les français faire
dans ce grand débat ils ont voulu nous
dire un il faut que les impôts baisse 2
il faut que le travail paye moi ce sont
mes deux obsessions à la sortie de ce
grand débat que travail paie plus
beaucoup de gens sur les ronds-points
ondées qui bossaient mais qu'il
n'arrivait pas à boucler leurs fins de
mois
et donc il faut continuer la politique
de baisse des charges est bien là l
objet de dérision les heures
supplémentaires et aussi pour dire ça y
est je le dis
baisser les impôts nous avons fait la
proposition le mouvement la république
en marche je représente a fait la
proposition de baisser de supprimer la
taxe d'habitation pour l'intégralité des
français parce que je pense que c'est
une mesure qui est attendu par les
classes moyennes
il faut aller rien de plus loin nous
avons commencé la baisse des impôts les
retraités bien j'ai aussi proposé
j'ai aussi proposé que l'on puisse
revenir sur la soude indexation des
pensions de retraite par rapport au
niveau de l'inflation
on pourra discuter du seuil mais je
crois que c'est un geste qu'il faut
apporter aussi pour les retraités
alors monsieur chacun laurent wauquiez
que chacun puisse y sont de la parole
près en ferronnerie tour où on va parler
de pouvoir d'achat de réussir et de dire
si vous me permettez leur envol sous le
nom là on veut offrir briser la règle du
jeu il ya eu un tirage au sort que
chacun puisse s'exprimer
une première fois c'est à dire d'arrêter
on y reviendra évidemment alors david
corps dans la question de l'impôt c'est
aussi celle la dépense publique regardez
notre sondage ifop pour ses news les
français ne sont pas prêts à payer plus
pour leurs services publics 75 % d'entre
eux disent non ils disent on en a pas
pour notre argent qu est ce que vous
leur dites vous savez je pense que c'est
son âge il révèle aussi le fait que
depuis des décennies on a dénigré
considérablement la fiscalité
moi je pense que c'est dommage dans une
société pour faire société pour
construire des solidarités oui il ya
besoin d'une fiscalité le problème qu'on
a vu c'est une lente dérive qui fait
qu'on fait toujours payer les mêmes et
les plus fragiles ceux qui sont captifs
et d'ailleurs l'exemple d'un gilet jaune
il est parfait quand on a augmenté sans
compensation la fiscalité du diesel à
qui on s'est attaqué à ceux qui ne
peuvent pas fuir l'impôt à ce qu'ils ne
peuvent qu ils ne peuvent pas faire de
bonification fiscale et d'évasion
fiscale dans votre graphique sur les
dépenses de l'état vous avez oublié à
paramètres qui sont tout ce qu'on
appelle les niches fiscales
la totalité des niches fiscales en
réalité c'est ça le premier budget de
l'état et donc on organise l'évasion
fiscale et donc effectivement c'est ce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas et celles qui ne
peuvent pas fuir l'impôt qui continuent
de le pays
la fiscalité pour qu'elle soit acceptée
pour qu'elles soient acceptables david
cormand elle a besoin d'être juste quand
on bénéficie d'une niche fiscale on
participe à l'évasion fiscale à vos yeux
non on capte monde participe à la
capacité de pouvoir détourner la pause
et il ya des cabinets qui sont très bien
payés
pour vous expliquer comment vous pouvez
échapper là pour va parler d'europe et
on va parler y compris des paradis
fiscaux au sein même de l'europe qui
participent à cette évasion fiscale ou
en tout cas à cette optimisation fiscale
c'est le terme plus pudiques qu'on
utilise en ces termes je vais finir sur
la question de la fiscalité pour qu'elle
soit acceptable et acceptée il faut
qu'elle soit juste
il faut qu'on comprenne ce que l'on en
fait hélas quand on voit que tout ce qui
est la transition énergétique s'apaisent
pilote dans le budget de l'état
on voit bien qu'il ya une injustice
parce que quelles sont les dépenses
imposées aujourd'hui des ménages ce sont
des dépenses imposées liés directement à
l'environnement et à l'écologie c'est
les transports c'est le chauffage ce
sont toutes ces questions là et donc si
on veut en avant juste il faut un impôt
qui soient utilisées et qui permettent
on y reviendra dans un instant à cette
fiscalité verte
nicolas dupont aignan la crise du
consentement à l'impôt aujourd'hui on le
voit à travers cette étude non à 75%
pour payer plus d'impôts pour de
meilleurs services publics mais écoutez
il y avait je crois une une gilet jaune
qui avait dit quelque chose très juste
ça a commencé comme ça d'ailleurs
c'était ou valve pognon c'était très
juste en fait parce que on n'a jamais
payé autant et on n'a jamais eu autant
des services publics dégradés la
ruralité souffle
les infirmières souffre on a
l'impression qu'on dilapide l'argent
public est en vérité moi ça m'amuse
parce que chacun va venir là il va
promettre une baisse d'impôts parce que
les élections dans quelques semaines
mais si on ne s'attaque pas d'abord à la
réduction des gaspillages des
gaspillages surréaliste et si on ne
s'attaque pas à la création de richesse
c'est à dire amener plus d'emplois en
france relocaliser ce qui est parti dans
les autres pays on passera ne passerez
votre vie organiser des débats sur quels
impôts en baisse quel impôt augmente
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a été pris à
son propre piège
il a fait les vases communicants qu'est
ce qu'on propose à debout la france ces
choses très simples on est les seuls à
avoir chiffré suite à la crise et gilet
jaune un plan de réduction des
gaspillages mais drastique mais pense
attaquants comme ça avait été fait avant
aux infirmières aux policiers en
s'attaquant eux à la fraude sociale
colossal notamment les fausses cartes
vitale en s'attaquant aux coûts de
l'immigration quéréel en s'attaquant aux
coûts l'union européenne qui est de
l'aider l'iran en s'attaquant au train
de vie de l'état
on peut économiser 32
milliards et on les bascules sur les
retraités pour ré indexer les pensions
de retraite car la moindre des choses
c'est que ce soit indexée sur
l'inflation ont le bascule sur les
services publics hockey et on le bascule
sur et ce match sera l'occasion d'en
débattre
une tva à 0 % 0 pour soi pour des
produits de première nécessité est un
passé vous le savez très bien à ce
moment pourquoi c'est impossible
les règles moi je ne me situe pas dans
cette europe là à vous lire je ne veux
pas en sortir je veux la réformer et l'a
remplacé et il est inadmissible que pour
les gens les plus de modèles du prix ne
puisse pas décidé d'une baisse de tva à
zéro pour cent sur des produits prône la
corse mais simplement les élections
européennes arrive puisque vous en
parlez comment on fait pour convaincre
nos 26 partenaires qu'il faut changer
les taux de tva et créer un taux zéro
mais eux ont négocié ça veut dire qu'à
un moment l'un des voix si je ne joue
plus on va revenir sur ces questions ne
reprenne précisément du troc votre
réponse l'idiome ça c'est à vous la
parole vous proposer le retour de l' isf
dans un pays et le champion d'europe des
prélèvements regarder ces chiffres
eurostat pour pouvoir comparer le taux
de prélèvements obligatoires dans notre
pays
48 2 4 % en suède 44,9 % en italie et 42
4% et l'allemagne 42 5%
oui bah je propose effectivement un ss
vert pour pouvoir financer la transition
énergétique parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison que ce soit ceux qui ont
manifesté après le mois de novembre qui
payent la facture de la transition
mais la bonne question c'est celle qu'a
posée lors invoquer l'a dit le problème
c'est qu'ils payent mais je suis
d'accord
le problème c'est qu'ils payent et ce
qui n'est pas payée par les grandes
fortunes
il est effectivement payée par tous les
autres c'est ce qui se passe avec
monsieur guérini depuis deux ans au fond
toutes les mesures qui sont prises les
unes après les autres sont faites pour
rattraper précisément ce qui a été donné
aux grandes fortunes et donc les
retraités passent à la caisse
et ainsi de suite les emplois aidés les
apl etc etc et donc la question c'est
effectivement qui paye ensuite entendu
cela dit ça se guérit ni dire il faut
que le travail paye mais ici on est tous
d'accord il faut que le travail paye
mais ne le ferez sais pas ce qui se
passe depuis deux ans pourquoi parce que
vous avez créé la flat tax
la flat tax c'est quoi c'est que ce sont
aujourd'hui ceux qui vivent de leurs
dividendes qui vivent de leur rente qui
est de la spéculation qui aujourd'hui
sont moins imposés qu'un ouvrier qui
rentrent l'impôt sur le revenu à 14%
vous avez fixé un taux pour les rentiers
de 12.8 voilà la réalité et c'est la
raison pour laquelle répond on pourrait
être d'accord avec vous à répondre aux
phrases on les connaît simplement il ya
une réalité qui s'impose et votre et
c'est la raison de la colère est plus
long c'est la raison pour laquelle il ya
des gilets jaunes en france alors qu'il
y en a nulle part en europe parce que
vous avez semé la discorde la zizanie
tout simplement parce que les gens
voient bien qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
problème de cohésion et la cohésion
la seule façon d'y parvenir c'est d'être
juste marine le pen des annonces des
annonces vont être faites l'issue du
grand débat national
vous avez soutenu cette grogne fiscale
lorsqu'elle a démarré le président de la
république vous regarde
est ce que vous attendez concrètement
comme baisses d'impôts des annonces vont
être fait des semaines que ça dure un
unique rail assure anne ne vois-tu rien
venir
qu'attendez vous aurez qui poudroie et
de baisses d'impôts doit pour l'instant
quel baisses d'impôts marine le pen
d'abord permettez moi de vous dire que
j'aimerais bien que de temps en temps il
ya des gens qui viennent dire bah voilà
nous avons participé à l'aggravation
fiscal dont le pays parce que personne
n'est responsable
or je suis navré de vous dire que en
2007 y avait 45 vers 8 8 milliards pour
l'impôt sur le revenu il était à 56 5
milliards en 2012
j'évoquais il était à 70 3 millions en
mais ce fort mais personne n'est
responsable donc déjà si on pouvait
commencer avec la classe politique qui
dit voilà nous on est responsable on a
augmenté et aujourd'hui on a créé les
conditions d'une exaspération fiscal qui
fait que les gens juste n'arrivent plus
à payer l'impôt non seulement ils
n'arrivent plus à le payer
il ne consentent plus à cet impôt mais
il ne consentent lui à la dépense
et ça ça posera un problème de
représentativité c'est à dire qu'ils
disent mais nous on n'est pas d'accord
avec la manière dont on dépend s'impose
d'abord on comprends pas parce que plus
on paye moins on a des services publics
de bonne qualité plus on paye pur mieux
dérembourser les médicaments
plus on a des forfaits hospitaliers plus
la justice est lente moins il ya de
police et de sécurité dans le pays
et c'est vrai que c'est là l'un mais
quelle info moi non mais pardon mais
c'est intéressant de savoir quand même
ça c'est important mais le camp lance je
vais vous dire je sais que je crois je
crois que les français ne veulent plus
payer pour les migrations
voilà je vous dis clairement il ne
veulent plus payer pour l'immigration
ils ne veulent plus payer les 1 milliard
à l'aide médicale d'état
quand un sur trois renonce à se soigner
il ne veut plus payer pour les logements
qu'il faut trouver absolument pour les
migrants alors même qu'il y à des
français qui sont dans la rue et qui
attendent depuis des années qui parfois
il continue d'y mourir voilà ils sont
plus d'accord avec ça et ça je pense que
il faut évidemment posé cette question
là sur la table maintenant il ya des
choix
gouverner c'est choisir eh bien nous
nous faisons des choix le choix c'est de
rétablir lisf et de baisser l'impôt sur
le revenu comme nous l'avions proposé en
le soir c'est notre réponse le choix
c'est de ne pas avantager les grands
groupes pour les entreprises avec le cic
eux qui n'a entraîné aucune création
d'emploi mais plutôt les tpe pme parce
que ce sont elles qui a création à tant
de temps de parole marine le pen alors
adrien 4,9 vous voulez faire aussi payer
les plus riches récupérer l'argent de la
fraude fiscale est-ce que vous avez
imaginé combien de fonctionnaires il
fallait recruter à bercy pour cela ah
c'est sûr qu'il en faut plus que ce qui
lie actuellement et des 3500 qu'ont
disparu depuis quelques années mais sur
la question de la fiscalité certains
lisent l'issue du grand débat en disant
il faut baisser les impôts pas du tout
d'ailleurs les gens disent pas faut
baisser les impôts et dispos baisser nos
impôts
précisément parce que ce sont les
contribuables les plus modestes en
matière de fiscalité ce qu'on peut dire
d'entrée de jeu c'est qu'emmanuel macron
a plus que mérité son titre de président
des riches
depuis le début de son quinquennat c'est
24 milliards de cadeaux aux plus riches
et aux entreprises
les 25 milliards dans le même temps de
retirer dans la sphère sociale
au global alors moi je veux bien qu'on
met en cause sans cesse l'impôt mais
vous l'avez rappelé dans votre reportage
ça financé services publics et jeudi à
messieurs guérini évoqué que baisser la
dépense publique ça ne fait pas un
projet politique et que le résultat du
bilan de ces politiques c'est que depuis
dix ans il se ferme un bureau de poste
par jour et une école par jour
quand 20 ans la moitié des maternités
ont fermé donc il faut le dire la
dépense publique ça sert et c'est utile
et d'ailleurs il ya une demande de
service public mais quand et comment les
français ne pas griller plus d'un pétale
lé bon c'est pas les français la plupart
des français notamment les plus
mobilisées maintenant parlons de la
fiscalité on détaille l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune
évidemment ça ne fait pas toute une
politique fiscale mais la charge
symbolique qui a consisté à redistribuer
un million d'euros au sens français les
plus riches sans qu'on ait vu d'ailleurs
qu'ils aient bloqué un quelconque rond
point pour le demander n'est pas
acceptable avec les sf ou les 3
milliards si on y récupérer vous
financer 60 mille embauches
d'enseignants
alors on nous dit parfois mais si on met
lisf les riches partent alors après on
dit que c'est nous qui caricature on les
riches mais c'est vous qui en faites des
évadés fiscaux en puissance en pensant
qu'avec les sept ils vont s'en aller
la vérité c'est que quand il y avait les
sf d'à peine 0 2% des assujettis qui
s'en aller sans qu'on puisse d'ailleurs
prouvé que c'était pour des raisons
fiscales donc rétabli csf première chose
ensuite je termine mon jeu être complet
à l'apparat sur cette question faudrait
aussi qu'on s'attaque véritablement à la
question de la fraude et de l'évasion
fiscale parce que selon des rapports
très sérieux s'apaise entre 80 et 100
milliards c'est à dire tenez vous bien
plus que les recettes de l'impôt sur le
revenu plus que le budget de l'éducation
et de la défense
réunis plus que le déficit dont on nous
rabat les oreilles à longueur de journée
pour nous demander par des efforts donc
il faut des moyens pour lutter là dessus
vous avez raison et je termine en
matière de justice fiscale je formule
une proposition claire les quatorze
tranches d'impôt pour lisser les forts
entre tous et faire en sorte que toutes
celles et ceux qui gagnent moins de 4000
euros par mois et vous savez que ça fait
du monde dans ce pays paie moins
d'impôts plus la tva avec les taux
différenciés je crois que ça ferait un
bon début saï saï bérénice holly sf
monsieur quatre mains vous allez quand
il y avait les sf est ce qu'il y avait
moins de chômage un pays non c'est tous
les capteurs et nous avons fait dix mais
monsieur guérini est ce que je ne
faisais pas coupé vous avez raison mais
aussi avec les sf ce que vous mais est
ce qu'il y avait plus de pouvoir d'achat
pour les plus modestes je ne crois pas
quand il avait lui sfs compris plus
d'emplois je ne crois pas notre
politique le choix que nous avons fait
c'est de faire en sorte que les ménages
les plus aisés puissent effectivement
investir dans les entreprises
je crois que pour créer des emplois pour
vaincre le sujet de la pauvreté c'est
pas les uns contre
les autres se guérissent uns avec les
autres et depuis que nous sommes nous
avons créé plus d'emplois que nous
intéresser cette année tels moyens
n'avaient les entoure en même temps
industriel minéraux ses dirigeants
j'essaie et cela fait 15 ans laura
flessel de les terminer
cela fait 15 ans effectivement que nous
n'avions pas créé d'emplois industriels
dans ce pays nous sommes en train de
retourner la situation et ça ça va créer
des emplois informels bougerait pas pour
à l'interpellation de monsieur
rapidement je réponds à raconter
appellation bon d'abord sur le
rétablissement de l'usf vous aura pas
échappé que selon les enquêtes d'opinion
77% des français sont pour son
rétablissement je suis d'accord avec ses
77 % c'est vous qu'êtes à minorité dans
cette affaire ce précisément mais vous
avez la cohérence de votre propos vous
vous pensez que celles et ceux qui ont
le plus c'est une position que je
comprends tout à fait celles et ceux qui
ont le plus réinvestissent dans
l'activité productive de votre pays je
pense que vous vous trompez monsieur
guérini le capitalisme notre époque
n'est pas celui que vous rêvez
malheureusement la vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la répartition des
bénéfices dans notre pays vous allez
voir c'est un tableau très simple et je
m'arrêterai là qui fait que la machine
peut pas être relancé c'est que les
bénéfices vont à peu près à 67% pour les
actionnaires on est d'ailleurs les
champions du monde en la matière parce
qu'on parle souvent de dépenses
publiques ou les champions d'europe
n'ont en oublie de dire qu'on est
champion du monde s'il vous plaît
les dividendes versés aux actionnaires
il ya seulement 25 petits % pour les
investissements productifs et 5 rien 80
vélos services et monsieur quatre mains
sous le capitalisme dont je rêve c'est
un pays et vous rêvez monsieur de la
moitié dit que je ne rentre pas prises
françaises ne soient pas détenues par
des étrangers et donc moi effectivement
à lens je fais le souhait non que ce
soit les investisseurs français qui me
créer des entreprises est allé après my
la semag énormément parler quand même
dans le fake pour moi parce que dans le
débat que nous avons eu à l'assemblée
et oui dans le fait que parce que
l'argent qui vous avez démobilisés que
vous avez restituer aux grandes fortunes
vous n'aurez pas demandé de n'y a pas de
conditions vous auriez pu dire
effectivement exonère mais à la
condition car gens s'investissent en
france aujourd'hui vous pouvez investir
dans un fonds vautour y compris qu'il va
déposer des entreprises françaises est
malgré tout ne plus payer les sf c'est
ça la politique organisée il y avait un
objectif qui existait auparavant lisf
pme qui remettait aux gens qu'ils
investissaient dans les pme françaises
de pouvoir être exonéré d'une part de
leur impôt sur la fortune
même ça vous l'avez supprimés mais même
ça donc on pallie ce qu'il est issu et
trouve à avancer le permanent et c'est
qu'ils y croient que ce qui va faire que
les français avaient brisé les
entreprises tout à l'heure mais d'avoir
des politiques connues et faire en fait
et ça effectivement c'est que cela
faisait desana d'ameuter devrait perdre
vous avez la parole dans notre cas c'est
ce que voulait évoquer la taxe carbone
et la fiscalité sur les carburants
monsieur guérini moyac sur ce que je
n'arrive pas à comprendre c'est que vous
n'arriviez pas à comprendre le sentiment
d'injustice que des français et
notamment des retraités on va seulement
est-ce que vous pouvez comprendre que
sur l' isf
l'idée qu'on puisse à baisser
massivement l'impôt de ceux qui sont les
plus riches dans notre pays il n'y a pas
de haine sociale dans ce que je dis tout
en augmentant les impôts des retraités
qui n'arrivent pas à s'en sortir tout en
baissant les apl que c'est insupportable
pour les gens qui ressentent ça d'une
manière profondément injuste que lorsque
vous expliquez que vous allez augmenter
le prix de l'essence
lorsque après les gilet jaune vous
expliquer comment augmenter encore de 5
% le prix de l'électricité au moins de
juin
ils n'en peuvent plus et ressemble
évidemment un profond sentiment
d'injustice est pas comptable ça
monsieur guérini s'est pas que des
chiffres
c'est pas des courbes c'est l'heureux
soir il ne doit y avoir un responsable
politique du cerveau dans le peuple
français mais témoin marine le pen à
rien car vous avez tous les deux dépassé
les trois minutes s'il vous plaît
séverine la maîtresse d'un ministre que
l'on puisse avancer s'il vous plaît
adrien 4 9 avril ya quatre ans vous avez
dépassé marine le pen en rien qu'à
tenace et stanislas green hill et les
trois minutes on va avancer dans le
débat la question de la taxe carbone a
été évoquée la fiscalité sur les
carburants avec les téléspectateurs de
ces news puisse regarder ce graphique
aujourd'hui les carburants flambe à
nouveau en raison de la hausse des prix
du pétrole alors que la hausse des taxes
en 2019 a été annulée par le
gouvernement simple exemple un litre de
gazole aujourd'hui c'est un euro 473 en
date du 6 avril laurent wauquiez vous
souhaitez annuler la hausse de la taxe
carbone de 2018 ce qui nous ferait si on
calculait le litre de gazole à 1 euros
40 aujourd'hui
ça fait un gros trou dans le budget de
l'état sans avoir l'impression que le
carburant est bon marché mais pardon ça
fait surtout un gros trou dans le budget
de ceux qui travaillent vous me
permettrez d'abord de noter que monsieur
guérini est resté moins de 15 secondes
sur la situation des retraités sa
décharge et notées çà m'a pas échappé
ensuite monsieur guérini nous dit je
veux une politique favorable à ceux qui
travaillent mais quelle est la première
chose qui handicape ceux qui travaillent
chez moi en haute loire les gens ils
vont pas travailler que le métro il
montre avec leurs voitures le plein
d'essence c'est notamment ce qui pèsent
extrêmement lourd sur le budget de ceux
qui vont travailler
vous l'avez rappelé le gouvernement a
mis en oeuvre en 2018
une taxe qui est appliquée encore
aujourd'hui sur l'essence et qui
contribue à renchérir de façon
importante le coût de l'essence
monsieur guérini vous ai posé la
question il ya quinze jours
vous ne m'avez pas répondu je vous ai
posé une question vous demandant très
clairement et très simplement
cette taxe que vous avez commencé à
appliquer en 2018 était dans votre
programme et les français pas du tout et
vous le savez très bien mais chacun
pourra vérifier parce que déjà la
dernière fois vous aviez menti je vous
le rappelle je vous rappelle que vous
avez durci la pente et vous l'avez
augmenté mais chacun pourra le vérifier
quand même dans votre programme pas du
tout je leur ai je le répète encore une
fois vous mentez par non mais vous avez
considérablement durci face à marin le
programme de françois hollande
considérablement vous l'avez augmenter
de façon importante
maintenant j'aimerais bien qu'on essaie
d'être un peu sérieux et d'avancer la
question que je vous pose est simple
vous avez décidé en 2018 une taxe sur
l'essence et le carburant
elle est toujours en avril est toujours
appliquée la question que je vous pose
cette pâte ce que les français quand ils
prennent leur plein d'essence
aujourd'hui continue à payer
vous voyez que la facture de l'essence a
considérablement augmenté à nouveau
est ce que vous vous engagez oui ou non
à la supprime me suis exprimée face à
2018 simple sur ce sujet non je me suis
engagé à maintenir les suppressions de
taxes que nous avions prise c'est comme
un garçon 2019
pas de nouvelles taxes locales à ma
question la mairie en cas d'incendié
l'outil taxe carbone dont l'objet de la
sq est sûre il est important de dire
c'est avec ça
qu'est-ce qu'on finance en l'occurrence
on a financé le fait que les français
puissent plus facilement la crise elle
est ce que vous vous engagiez la
supprimer ou sans rénover leur logement
on a investi dans les énergies
renouvelables nogales six points je suis
donc vous
8 pas pour 2011 voilà oui je suis
favorable à ne pas augmenter la
fiscalité souriant dont vous avez
beaucoup de retard sur le temps de
parole sur cette fiscalité verte est ce
qu'elle est pour vous uniquement une
fiscalité punitive
c'est le modèle économique actuel qui
est punitif et c'est la mode de vie
qu'on a imposé aux français qui est
punitif savez quand on parle du prix de
l'essence et vous l'avez rappelé je vous
remercie de l'avoir fait ce qui est
déterminant c'est le prix du baril et
j'ai un scoop pour vous le prix du baril
va continuer à augmenter et aujourd'hui
on est dans un système où on a fait une
promesse intenable à nos concitoyennes à
nos concitoyens
on leur a dit votre autonomie sera
garantie par votre automobile vous
pourrez continuer à rouler en voiture
vous pourrez continuer à être éloignés
des centres villes on va pouvoir
continuer à fermer des cdd des services
publics près de chez vous mais vous
pourrez toujours vous débrouiller parce
qu'il y aura votre voiture et que c'est
pas cher ça c'est un mensonge et donc la
question c'est comment on fait une
fiscalité carbone qui est juste sir qui
ne rend pas les gérants captif pour
libérer du pouvoir de vivre pour les
françaises et les français
comment vont elles tomber comment le
fait-on en réduisant tout ce qui est les
dépenses imposées si quoi les dépenses
imposées pour en foyer j'en parlais tout
à l'heure c'est être obligé d'avoir de
bagnols plutôt qu'une 0 c'est être
obligé de surchauffe et chez soi parce
qu'on a une maison mal isolée c'est
l'obsolescence programmée
parce qu'on vous fait acheter des
produits qui se dégradent très vite
c'est le modèle alimentaire et la
surconsommation dans les grandes
surfaces et donc en changeant de modèles
et j'entendais parler tout à l'heure
d'un capitalisme qui ferait rêver
aucun capitalisme ne peut faire rêver
parce que la logique du capitalisme
c'est le productivisme
c'est continuer à accumuler des
richesses et forcer les gens à
surconsommer
tant qu'on changera pas ce modèle là il
n'y aura pas de solution à la
décroissance on retourne dans les
grottes préhistoriques
il savait la décroissance dit non je
suis environnementale et la décroissance
du mal vivre qu'on est en train de voir
exploser partout c'est plutôt une bonne
idée moi je crois effectivement qu'on
est de toute façon dans une poche
croissance la croissance des trente
glorieuses c'est terminé et toutes
celles et tous ceux qui nous font
consentir des sacrifices inhumain pour
faire revenir cette croissance qui ne
reviendra pas manteau j'en ai donc là du
fonio changer ce modèle là nicolas
dupont aignan je vous vois vous agacé
depuis des normes et à les écouter il
n'y a pas un débat sans qu on passe dix
minutes sur l' isf
moi je suis pour le rétablissement de la
sf avec une conditions d'exonération
si la personne qui est riche investis
sur le territoire français je pense que
le problème c'est pas plus ou moins
d'impôts c'est la manière dont on les
perçoit et je reviens d'ailleurs à la
sphère la taxe carbone le gouvernement
ne veut pas remettre en cause sa hausse
de 2018 je le regrette parce que nos
concitoyens se sont pas ceux qui
prennent leur voiture dans le cantal en
lozère ou dans les alpes qui polluent je
suis désolé ce sont ces cargos immense
avec des containers qui viennent de
chine et vous avez signé le cétacé dire
ce traité de libre-échange avec le
canada
c'est cette mondialisation qui fait
qu'on apporte des produits de très loin
si aussi nicolas dupont aignan nicolas
dupont aignan simplement les transports
sur le territoire français à 7 36 ans de
talent de gaza et fait éclater le gars
qu'on arrête avec le gaz à effet de
serre n'existe pas sur notre territoire
il existe mais je peux vous dire que les
centrales à charbon allemandes ou
polonaises pollue plus que la petite
voiture du français c'est ça va aller
travailler 50 hier des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre en france les tranchées
mais la france est le pays qui polluent
le moins qui polluent beaucoup moins
grâce à son électricité nucléaire est
jeune et assez qu'on culpabilise les
français en permanence d'être
responsables de la pollution du monde
alors qu'on délocalise toutes nos
productions dans des pays qui polluent
énormément et que d'ailleurs c'est ça
qui est incroyable les cargos qui amène
les produits eux ont un carburant qui
est des taxes et c'est à dire que celui
qui bosse durement l'entrepreneur qui
artisans ont le surtaxe est ce qui
importe des produits qui donc
nourrissent le chômage qui mettent au
chômage
nos concitoyens sont détaxés tout est
fait dans notre pays pour favoriser les
importations
pour créer le chômage de masse donc la
question de la fiscalité j'insiste
viendra de ces deux des taxes et ceux
qui produisent en france et là vous
verrez que le chômage revient le lin
blanc pouvoir reviendra et qu'on aura à
ce moment là attention aux lapsus
on aura à ce moment-là moins d'impôts à
payer car si à un million d'emplois de
relocaliser et ben vous verrez que la
facture diminuera pour sud rien quelle
chance
adria 4,9 vous proposer un grand plan de
développement des énergies renouvelables
comment faire sans faire flamber la
facture des français
bon d'abord ce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'en matière de climat c'est un modèle
économique dans son ensemble qui est mis
en cause et compris la jeunesse qui se
mobilisent
voilà comme on l'a vu récemment elle ne
dit pas il faut verdir un peu le
programme de monsieur macron interdire
les pailles des tout y est en plastique
comme on a pu le voir elle met en cause
un modèle économique parce qu'elle a
compris que ce modèle basé sur le
productivisme basé sur la croissance
sans fin n'était pas viable
moi je ne suis pas scientifique mais les
scientifiques nous disent que nous avons
12 ans devant nous pour changer de
modèle économique sans quoi on rentre
dans une ère de grande catastrophe que
mêmes scientifiques n'arrivent pas à
prévoir
par conséquent bien mal inspiré celui
qui pensera qu'on peut régler les
problèmes avec une simple fiscalité
écologique qui d'ailleurs n'en est pas
une puisque fait dès lors que les gens
n'ont pas d'alternative et c'est
d'ailleurs sur ce fait là qu'a commencé
le mouvement des gilets jaunes c'est que
les gens vous disent moi n'est pas le
choix que de prendre ma voiture
individuelle tant que les transports en
commun seront pas gratuits tant que je
n'aurai pas d'alternative en matière
d'écologie ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant c'est se hisser à la hauteur
de l'enjeu
si nous avons douze ans pour changer de
modèle économique il faut inscrire la
règle vers toute l'activité économique
doit être basée sur ce fait qu'on ne
prend pas davantage la nature que ce
qu'elle peut reconstituer pour ça il
faut donc planifié écologiquement et je
vais vous dire je pense que c'est un
projet beaucoup plus enthousiasmant que
la compétition et la concurrence libre
et non faussée parce que faire la
planification écologique ça veut dire
mettre beaucoup de monde au travail
rien que sur le modèle agricole ces
quatre cent mille paysans à 4 nas voilà
un projet la règle je pense les gens
seraient plus intéressés à se lever le
matin là pour aller faire une
compétition dépourvu de sens s'il
tentait que c'est bien la réalité de la
vie humaine sur terre qui est menacée la
règle verte de la france atomise jeu
j'attire votre attention sur le
chronomètre fait attendre il interrogé
avant d'autres qui sont résorbés à
olivier
olivier faur vous avez justement un peu
de crédit de deux temps la taxe carbone
comme outil de la transition énergétique
on en a parlé ça a été rappelé aussi
elle a été votée sous le quinquennat
précédent est ce que vous défendez
l'outil mais je n'ai pas l'habitude de
me cacher derrière mon petit doigt et
donc effectivement cette taxe carbone
elle a été adoptée courageusement par
cette majorité précédente
pourquoi parce qu'il faille donner un
signal prix c'est quand même fantastique
dans ce pays si elle prit un signal
signal écrivant veut dire qu'il fallait
effectivement faire en sorte que ne soit
pas moins cher de consommer du diesel
par rapport à l'essence
on ne peut pas continuer à laisser
penser à augmenter les deux d'ailleurs
non nous avons moitié du diesel marine
le pen je vous ai laissé parler je vais
finir donc permettez moi quand même de
dire que effectivement il fait donner ce
signal prix faire en sorte qu' on puisse
comprendre notamment les constructeurs
automobiles qu'il n'y avait plus à
investir dans le diesel mais chercher à
aller vers des villes du constructeur et
le diesel automobile ici vous dire non
trente ans que il vaut mieux acheter un
diesel parce que quand vous achetez un
diesel ça vous coûte moins cher que de
rouler à l'essence forcément vous
achetez un diesel et donc il fallait
faire comprendre aux constructeurs
automobiles qu'il n'y aurait plus
davantage compétitif a vanté les mérites
du diesel par rapport à l'essence
simplement ce qui s'est passé pendant le
quinquennat qui viennent d'entamer c'est
que le gouvernement de monsieur macron
il a augmenté la trajectoire de 55
milliards sur cinq ans donc évidemment
ça va passer inaperçu ce qui était
simplement une trajectoire qui était une
trajectoire soutenable par les français
est devenu une trajectoire insoutenable
pourquoi ils l'ont fait mais là encore
parce qu' il fallait payer les fameux
cadeaux fiscaux faits aux plus riches
c'est quand même une coïncidence mais à
chaque fois c'est la même chose quand il
manque 5 milliards on le prélève
toujours sur les français là où le
prélevés précédemment sur les français
les plus riches et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut un bon vivement
être courageux dire que nous avons
effectivement dix ans pour sauver la
planète
si on veut la sauver la planète il
faudra effectivement investir
durablement dans la transition
écologique et je finis
fermant lettre pour dire que ces
milliards de plus qu'ils ont fait pays
qui nous ont fait payer qu'à la taxe
carbone en réalité seuls 20 % étaient
destinés à la transition énergétique et
donc si vous voulez un complexe carbone
qui soit juste
il faut non seulement ce tribunal sera
proportionnée mais il faut figurer en
produits soient renvoyés vers les
français qu'ils sont captifs une
réaction mais après stanislas guerre et
medavoy la gauche aux on n'arrête pas de
saucissonner dans ces émissions avaient
à la taxe carbone vous en pensez quoi
mais est-ce qu'on peut quand même
revenir au budget des français parce que
la taxe carbone elle est arrivée sur une
augmentation en 2018 de 21 % du gaz de
30% du fuel de 22% du gazole de 14,60
naissance du péage de l'alcool du tabac
des cartes grises du contrôle technique
et j'en passe et des meilleurs et puis
on fait payer les gens sur le parking
des hôpitaux publics il faut payer
et puis l'intégralité des parkings
souterrains par ils sont payants et
cetera et cetera et cetera
et c'est là où ils ont de l'eau encore
une fois jusqu'à là jusqu'à la racine du
nez et on leur dit oh vous allez quand
même par ali pour quelques centimes mais
c'est pas qui rase et qui meurt voilà
c'est aussi simple que ça c'est déjà la
pression sur la paire à l'acharnement
s'exaspère deuxièmement sur le modèle
économique permettez moi mais encore une
fois c'est pas avec une taxe carbone
qu'on va sauver la planète
on va sauver la planète en changeant
radicalement le modèle économique et moi
je propose de changer une chose s'est
inversée le coût de la distance tant
qu'on continuera à accepter que ce qui
vient de 10000 km coûte moins cher que
ce qui vient de 10 km alors on mourra et
on fera mourir la planète
brido délocalisera et on
désindustrialise rats et on verra les
agriculteurs disparaître et de surcroît
nous mangerons des choses douteuses
parce qu'en réalité on sait très bien
que notamment sur le plan agricole les
productions que l'import et le pen sont
importunés le compte de
avec darina d'un seul mot avec d'énormes
terminer votre famille sont minimes par
rapport à celles qui sont imposés à nos
agriculteurs et sont dangereuses pour la
centaine le pen merci beaucoup alors
simplement d'un mot pour les
téléspectateurs et et nos auditeurs sur
europe 1 rappelé que les questions
d'europe et de climat on le sent bien on
le voit bien sont transversales à toutes
ces thématiques stanislas green vous
avez été éclairement interpellé à
plusieurs reprises scénario je voudrais
jetez-vous et saint paul à monsieur
guérini venez vous venez de prononcer le
mot qui manque depuis plusieurs minutes
c'est le mot de l'europe parce que si
nous voulons justement trouver les
solutions pour la transition écologique
c'est au niveau européen appelant à le
faire le plus efficacement
c'est justement comme ça en mobilisant
les énergies aussi mais pas sur les
navires qui sont les vôtres et les
autres énergies pour certains nous
proposons puisque par le sujet du débat
ce soir c'est quelle france pour qu'elle
attaque sur les lectrices de sailor
mobiliser beaucoup plus massivement des
capitaux pour investir mais nous avons
fait la proposition de créer une banque
pour le climat nous avons été capables
de prévisions soit 6 à ces sujets
excusez moi mais si on se sait sa
décision répond pas si vous voulez on
parle de bébés en même temps je pense
qu'henri ambitieux et l'europe
ces programmes ont bondi à se glisser la
nef cela il faudra les jeux reprend la
parole nous parlions d'abord et on va
parler d'europe évidemment je viens de
le dire
ces sujets sont transversaux nous
parlions de pouvoir d'achat notre
sondage ifop réalisé pour cette émission
ce soir nous apprend quand on pose la
question aux français une fois les
dépenses payées
est ce qu'il vous reste de quoi épargner
la réponse est très claire c'est non à
60% tu prends la cfdt parle de pouvoir
de vivre le langage de tous les jours
revient le pouvoir d'achat l'idée c'est
celle d'une fin du mois confortable sans
avoir peur du coup de fil du banquier
alors leur avocat quel est votre
solution
est-ce qu'on augmente le smic comment
est ce qu'on fait pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux français
mais pardon on vient de le dire vous les
redistribuer de l'argent
commencez déjà par en prendre moins
quand on vous propose de baisser l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est du retour de pouvoir
d'achat
quand on dit qu'il faut revaloriser le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités qui ont
été les principales victimes de la
politique du gouvernement
c'est du pouvoir d'achat et ça pour que
ça marche
il ya une question qui est absolument
essentiel et qui est pas du tout abordé
par monsieur guérini c'est que encore
faut-il que pour baisser les impôts en
économie sur la dépense publique est
tout le problème de ce qui a été fait
depuis deux ans c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'économies sur la dépense publique et
il faut que ceux qui nous écoutent le
sache
eh bien ils ont je vais y répondre
immédiatement vie mais les écoles prix
qui régnait le maquereau est arrivé il a
dépensé plus d'argent en deux ans que
françois hollande en deux ans 20 8
milliards d'euros en deux ans de
françois hollande en augmentation des
parts publiques 44 milliards d'euros
d'augmentation de dépenses publiques je
voudrais sous moi je voulais devenir
année bat donc la première chose c'est
qu'il faut faire des économies
moi je viens d'une région la région vers
le rhône alpes que vous connaissez bien
dans ma région j'ai commencé par faire
quoi j'ai commencé par faire des
économies sur la dépense publique ce que
le gouvernement n'a pas fait donc en
baisse est due le nombre de
fonctionnaires en simplifiant nos
dispositifs ligne ou en enlevant des
agences administratives qui existe avec
par exemple 20 agences qui s'occupait
des costumes ou kiev en avait déjà été
retoqué par le son sur la gestion de
notre région c'est une drôle quand
d'alarmant mais je vais vous dire ce qui
compte le plus pour les habitants c'est
vous dire ce que c'est c'est pas d'avoir
été retoqué sur un petit susanna melzer
faire ce que je fais je vais vous dire
pourquoi et pourquoi je me permets de
vous donner y compris des tweets vous
devriez écouter mais je voulais entendre
jouer c'est pour ça que c'est bien et
j'aime bien ce genre de débat ça vous
permet d'entendre des jeux parfois vous
avez un petit peu mal à octobre qu'est
ce qu'on a fait en est une des rares
régions à voir baisser les taxes
ça devrait vous réjouir une des rares
régions on est une des rares régions
avoir réussi elles sont les écoles de
nouvelles baisses sur les dépenses de
fonctionnement c'est quoi les labs de
votre région ça m'intéresse parce que
c'est très peu les recettes 6 8% du
budget d'une région le réseau méditation
pour vous c'est toujours assez
extraordinaire parce que pour vous c'est
toujours des petits taxes non on a
baissé de taxes ou on a baissé les taxes
et les cartes grises
bravo mon ami les cartes grises à 0 sur
les véhicules propres je pense que ça
devrait vous réjouir
et on a également baissé la taxe sur les
carburants ça je pense par contre que ça
fait partie de nos points de divergence
en tout cas ce qui est clair c'est que
effectivement n'a montré dans notre
région quoi vous pouvez baisser les
impôts et vous pouvez baisser les taxes
je comprends que ça ne vous réjouissez
pas évident qu'avant c'est clairement
pas du tout la même option ou par les
deux nés en tout cas nous ait retoqué
pour laurent wauquiez dans la région
auvergne rhône alpes vous dans votre
programme europe ecologie les verts
on revient à un débat de 2017 vous
proposer un minimum social garanti
permanent inaliénable cumulables c'est
ce qui a été décrit dans votre programme
d'un mot vous avez un peu de temps vous
le financer comment ça a été fait par
damien carême à grande synthe par
exemple pour les gens qui sont soumis
aux en dessous du minimum du revenu
minimum
il ya un complément qui est donnée par
la mairie pour pouvoir sortir la
situation de misère le financer ou savez
moi je crois ça a été dit par d'autres
et je les dis d'ailleurs dans mon propos
liminaire moi je suis plutôt favorable à
la fiscalité
à condition qu'elle soit juste et
qu'elle permette de faire ce qu'elle ne
fait plus c'est redistribuées et donc il
faut prendre acquis aux plus riches et
aux followers
je vous dire ça tombe bien ce sont les
mêmes ce sont les mêmes qui sont qui
font beaucoup de profits en faisant des
dividendes sur des entreprises qui sont
très polluantes et ce sont ces
entreprises qui continuent à nous
maintenir dans un modèle qui nous fait
faire beaucoup de dépenses j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure sur les dépenses imposées
donc c'est de l'argent qui sait à
combien d'allers purement là le minimum
qui a été fait à grande synthe c'est
quand on est au dessus du minimum donc
c'est autour de 400 euros donc faut au
moins rattrapé sa à terme on souhaite
qu'ils montent vers 800 mille euros
marine le pen c'est ok j'ai pris nos
peines
marine le pen vous vous proposez une
prime de pouvoir d'achat pour les bains
je veux dire si j'allais de redonner foi
en l'argent de l'argent aux français il
ya plusieurs pistes 1 d'abord on
pourrait commencer parce que c'est
profondément injuste monsieur guérini
vous n'êtes pas seul responsable
d'ailleurs évoqué votre mouvement était
pareil la tva sur la tsr on paye en fait
une tva sur l'impôt très honnêtement
est-ce que c'est juste non c'est pas
juste de payer de la tva sur l'impôt
donc ça on pourrait déjà la supprimer ça
ferait quand même une baisse non
négligeable notamment de l'essence à la
pompe la csg voilà le meilleur moyen
peut-être de restituer de l'argent tous
les mois aux français ce serait de
baisser la cg par exemple parce que la
csg elle a commencé 1%
et puis aurait été au fur et à mesure
c'est monte monte monte monte pour
atteindre presque 10% aujourd'hui et
c'est insupportable c'est vous
y'a pas mais auraient été tous et 7 ces
prélèvements s'accumulent tous ces coups
s'accumulent ce dont je vous parlais
tout à l'heure qui sont aussi liés en
fait on fait au dalit et que vous avez
créé par exemple les péages g on a vendu
les autoroutes
et puis les français ont payé les
autoroutes et puis maintenant ce sont
des entreprises privées qui se sont
rendu acquéreur pour un prix dérisoire
de ces autoroutes et qui récupère la
manne et elle elle augmente c'est
société progressivement les péages et
tout est comme ça donc les français
juste ils n'ont à temps peuvent plus je
veux aller au bout de la logique
je trouve très bien que de l'autre bout
il faudra faire des économies et moins
très clairement je vous le dis nous
n'avons plus les moyens de prendre en
charge l'intégralité de l'immigration
qui pèsent sur notre pays nous ne
pouvons pas dans les médias sans marine
nous ne pouvait plus de 21 milliards et
demi de contribution à l'union
européenne alors que année après année
on va précisément par les marine le pen
gardé du temps puisqu'on va parler
terrain et j'avais du temps nicolas
dupont aignan avait dans le reste de
l'émission
moi je le pouvoir d'achat on a parlé des
impôts via les impôts mais le pouvoir
d'achat ce sont des dépenses contraintes
quotidiennes j'ai une question à
monsieur guérini comme par hasard vous
prévoyez d'augmenter le la taxe sur
l'électricité ça ça va être très concret
pour les français de près de 6%
d'ailleurs vous avez décalé après les
européennes seraient mieux c'est
considère que la dupont aignan pour être
précis en rien le gouvernement qui
décide de cette augmentation c'est la
commission de régulation de l'énergie en
satin d'être détendu on s'est mis des
règles absurdes
excusez moi on sait pas on a le droit
dans notre pays de penser différemment
de ceux qui ont mis des règles
complètement délirante qui fait qu' on
ne peut plus rien faire quand on est au
gouvernement je suis désolé si le
gouvernement veut changer les règles de
la fixation du prix de l'électricité il
peut faire voter une loi
donc moi je maintiens qu'il est
complètement aberrant d'augmenter encore
le prix l'électricité que les familles
n'en peuvent plus autre point c'est de
continuer la politique que de spoliation
des biens publics
est ce que les français savent et on en
parlera dans le débat sur l'europe que
les barrages hydroélectriques que nos
grands-parents ou construire la fin de
la guerre vont être privatisées de
manière scandaleuse
est ce qu on a eu l'exemple d'aéroports
de paris là et il faut tout faire pour
bloquer cette vente d'aéroports de paris
c'est de la spoliation public et la
question majeure qu'on a dans notre pays
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya des groupes
d'intérêts très proche de votre
président de la république car
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses c'est bank
of america était chargé de la
privatisation des aéroports de paris
c'est assez curieux vous pourrez
enquêter l'hypnose il va vous répondre
j'ai eu quelques je veux finir ma phrase
quand même excusez moi c'est que si on
laisse des oligarchies des castes
prendre possession du bien public du
bien public des français et bien faut
pas s'étonner après qu'ils rackettent
les français c'est ce qui s'est passé
sur les autoroutes et reconnaissait que
dès 2006 j'ai bataillé contre cette
privatisation scandaleuse donc le
pouvoir d'achat c'est pas simplement
l'impôt attention le temps c'est le fait
que nos concitoyens sont pressés de
partout de partout et il faut absolument
inverser la tendance
pardon vous avez vu la photo la méga
nîmes monsieur guérini sérieusement la
loi et gally je vais plus savoir quoi
l'algérie non mais pardon non mais parce
que qu'est ce que c'est quand même voir
les alims c'est la loi qui les avait
planté le prix des denrées alimentaires
est alors monsieur vous avez enfin je
sais plus quoi choisir qu'en réalité
tout cela allait servir pour augmenter
les marges des agriculteurs producteurs
arrivent en réalité les agriculteurs et
les haies et les producteurs n'ont rien
eu et les consommateurs on est arrivé à
l'automne on va parler de beaucoup de
sujets a par la suite et vous prenez
énormément de retard
je ne sais que je serai donc je vais
choisir de dire la vérité des fêtes
c'est peut-être ça qui sera le plus
simple ce soir dans ce débat c'est pour
la première année depuis bien longtemps
la réalité c'est qu'on a à la fois
baisser le déficit dans notre pays
déficit budgétaire il était à 3 4% quand
on est arrivé il ya 2,5 cette année nous
avons à baisser la dépense publique dans
notre pays
elle a augmenté pour les nanas de 0 03 %
d'inflation
je réponds à ce qui m'a été
c'est le chômage ils savent bien aimé
pouvoir d'achat tu vois très bien
décidément tout va très bien
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour le
parent d'achat baisser les impôts on en
a parlé d' avons commencé à le faire la
taxe d'habitation les charges sont au
travail d'avants défiscalisé les heures
supplémentaires
soyons un peu concret un sale j'ai sous
la main ici il ya même un 1500 sous la
pression des gilet jaune comme salarié
je vais essayer de finir valable mais
sous la presse à leurs disques à 1500
euros par an parce que nous avons
défiscalisé les heures supplémentaires
s'il fait deux heures de plus par
semaine
bah il va gagner grâce à sa 500 euros
net de plus par an
ça c'est concret donc faire en sorte que
le travail paie plus baisser les impôts
et des nos aînés parce que oui je crois
que les gilet jaune
cette crise sociale a dit aussi
l'inquiétude que les français avaient
les avis du vieillissement
eh bien j'ai parlé tout à l'heure doré
indexées les pensions sur l'inflation je
crois qu'il faut aller plus loin et en
étant dexia dépréciations d'un total si
je finis en quelques secondes comme on
va plus loin que le pied simplement je
veux le dire il faut aller plus loin
il ya un constat très simple c'est que
une place en maison de retraite ça coûte
environ 2000 euros
la retraite moyenne des ses 1300 euros
environ et donc j'ai donné l'ordre au
caire région du projet davantage c'est
la proposition que j'ai formulées aider
davantage en prenant en charge pour tous
les retraités qui en ont besoin un quart
du coût de la pension de retraite est
bien mais c'est une proposition série ça
répond qu'est-ce que c'est c'est un
prise en charge aujourd'hui
en réalité il ya une prise en charge qui
existe c'est un crédit d'impôt donc ça
bénéficie à ceux qui payent des impôts
et ça ne bénéficie pas à ceux qui ne
payent pas d'impôts d'alain je propose
de faire en sorte que ce soit une aide
directe mais remboursable sur leur
héritage 12e guérini mais je vais pas
prendre comme la ministre aux sections
ne mangeait pas de restitution déjà eu
l'occasion de l'un des simples moindre
mal et voudront tard pour devenir membre
et adriano dernier mode et la parole
depuis un moment
j'y reviendrai non mais pardon mais on
ne saute pas entendre ça monsieur
guérini nous dit en 2019
on a baissé le déficit c'est totalement
faux en 2019
le déficit se creuse et nous aurons le
pire déficit de la zone euro ce qui est
jamais arrivé dans l'histoire de la
france au cours des deux heures trente
de s'écouler défilent d'abord des deux
ans qui viennent de s'écouler
tous les pays européens ont réussi à
baisser leurs dettes sauf notre pays on
est le seul pays
européen à ne pas avoir réussi
sérieusement abaissé sa dette on est le
seul pays à avoir le record de la
dépense publique et des impôts et vous
venez monsieur des rennais en
fanfaronnant et en nous disant regardez
comme tout est beau et comment deux ans
on a tous rétablis vers le fin du fin ne
jamais baisser le numéro que vous venez
de faire sur les retraités donc si je
comprends bien
d'un côté vous avez appauvrit les
retraités de retraités sur 3 monsieur
guérini regardez-moi deux retraités sur
trois qui ont perdu du pouvoir d'achat
le président de la république regardez
le président de mes mouvements je vais
vous êtes un peu autoritaire a du nez je
crois qu'avec moi ça ne prendra pas mais
il ya une chose monsieur guérini que
j'aimerais bien que vous assumiez le
président de la république avait dit
pendant la campagne présidentielle je
préserverai le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
qu'est ce que vous avez fait de cette
promesse qu'est ce que vous avez fait
200 m et quand vous dites ici je suis
presque on revalorise les riads de
l'inflation sur juste une petite une
petite question là tu dis que j'aimerais
qu'ils soient précis qu'elle retraités
est-ce que vous acceptez ici ce qui est
notre demande de faire en sorte que tous
les retraités sont revalorisés de
l'inflation parce que moi ce que j'ai
entendu des propositions du gouvernement
c'est uniquement par les retraités dits
riches c'est à dire que pour un couple
de retraités qui est à 3000 euros ne
bénéficiera pas de la revalorisation de
l'inflation n'a pas la même conception
qu'on en reste que le président de la
république un responsable adria
cadenassant quelques adrien 4,9
oui parce que le chapitre c'est bien
pouvoir d'achat en quête de solutions
gramat je vais vous dire une chose mon
avis est que là aussi tout comme sur la
fiscalité est une question de
répartition
d'abord dans notre pays à 9 millions de
pauvres et dans le même temps on estime
que 30 % par dont 30 personnes à peu
près détiennent la même richesse que 40%
de la population française donc on a
bien un problème de répartition alors il
faut d'abord un plan d'urgence pour
celles et ceux qui sont les premiers
concernés
je pense que pour une carrière complète
pour contribuer au débat sur les
retraites il ne devrait pas y avoir une
retraite en dessous du smic
de la même manière il n'est pas
supportable que les minimas sociaux soit
à cette heure toujours sous le seuil de
pauvreté
ensuite en la question du pouvoir
d'achat moi je suis sensible à l'idée
que le travail paye
parce que voyez seul le travail produit
de la richesse soumettez du capital dans
un coffre que vous partez trois mois et
que vous revenez ci appelle travail
humain il ya de fortes chances que vous
retrouvez la même somme
or que s'est il passé depuis des années
sinon une prédation du capital
sur le travail qui est le cancer de
l'activité de ce pays qui l'empêchent de
relancer en 1981 on estime qu'un salarié
français travailler en moyenne neuf
jours par an pour rémunérer les
actionnaires
aujourd'hui nous sommes les champions du
monde des dividendes j'ai dit c'est en
moyenne 45 jours par an qu'un salarié
travaille pour venir exposer les
actionnaires j'ai vu que monsieur
guérini dans sa contribution au fameux
grand débat national avait proposé une
journée de travail supplémentaire pour
financer la dépendance une journée de
solidarité tient donc quelle bonne idée
que pensez vous de l'idée de demander à
ses chers actionnaires pourquoi pas de
supporter que quelques jours dans
l'année
les salariés ne travaillent pas pour les
enrichir c'est une solution ensuite et
je crois que je suis sans doute qu'un
seul peut-être même le seul sur ce
plateau être pour la hausse du smic et
je vais augmenter le smic avec la france
soumise de 15% pour le porter à 1326
euros nets
j'ai juste dans les mêmes termes à
témoin oui j'ai un résident à lever
demain d'autres sont pour la hausse du
smic mais je termine juste rapidement at
on précisé
il a terminé on aurait terminé s'il vous
plaît je termine
madame ferrari sur la termine smic pour
vous dire une chose je crois
profondément que l'augmentation des
salaires est bénéfique pour l'activité
du pays parce que contrairement à ceux
et celles qui détiennent le plus ce cas
beaucoup enrichi monsieur macron ceux à
qui vous augmenter leurs salaires quand
ils ont des bas revenus eux ils
investissent dans l'économie réelle
preuve s'il en fallait une les 10
milliards que vous avez concédé au gilet
jaune même si on peut admettre qu'ils
ont été assez mal dépensé et mal
attribués ont produit cet effet que la
croissance a augmenté
donc c'est bien la preuve quand vous
augmenter les bas revenus c'est
bénéfique pour l'activité donc il faut
garder les salaires
s'il vous plaît j'aurais juste préciser
quand même pour nos auditeurs et
téléspectateurs d'un seul mot que dans
le public il ya énormément de supporters
de minutes et vous êtes en retard vous
perdu mais pour les autres thèmes qui
sont chers mais c'est quand même
incroyable bas par le pouvoir d'achat je
passe une heure que pouvoir d'achat et
on fait comme si la seule solution
possible était une solution qui relevait
exclusivement de la baisse des impôts et
la baisse de la fiscalité mais d'abord
je voudrais dire quand même que ce
canton de besse la fiscalité et quand on
baisse
ensuite la dépense publique devrait
qu'on compare avec ce qui est comparable
regardez dans les pays qui sont vraiment
des pays d'inspiration libérale
effectivement on paye moins d'impôts
mais on paie plus d'assurance santé oms
vient à l'hôpital avec sa carte bleue
aux etats-unis par exemple vous avez
aujourd'hui 45% des dépenses qui sont
prises en charge par la collectivité
sassou le reste est pris en charge par
les américains eux mêmes en france ces
94 % de ce que vous dépensez pour votre
santé qui est pris en charge par la
collectivité
ça change tout et donc si on ne prend
pas cet argent là est bien que faut-il
faire il faut aussi peut être par les
salaires effectivement parce que c'est
quand même trop simple revient dans un
débat qui est un débat où on est
simplement un concours lépine de la
fiscalité mais pendant ce temps almeida
fils frotte les mains
personne ne m'interroge personnes je
finis quand même dingue ou laurence
ferrari quand même je suis en retard
largement donc en tard en retard en
retard
effectivement je suis en retard et ce
que je dis c'est que le medef est pour
l'instant il se frotte les mains mais
moi ce suisse a non seulement pour
augmenter le smic mais je suis aussi
pour qu'il y ait une discussion enfin
edf sur les minima de branche
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on sera non
pas seulement mais qu'il revaloriser non
pas seulement revaloriser les points
gagnants le bas de l'échelle sociale
mais aussi en vérité tous les salaires
cette migration elle a lieu tous les
quatre ans aujourd'hui il faut qu'elle
soit annuel pour qu'on puisse
effectivement faire en sorte que les
classes moyennes puissent aussi
bénéficier de la roseraie sur la sphère
du smic conçoit bien précis le problème
de fond dans notre pays c'est que celui
qui ne travaille pas et celui qui
travaille non pas une différence
suffisante de salaire
voilà pourquoi je pense que la seule
solution d'augmenter les sérieux ne pas
augmenter le smic brut pour pas que les
tpe et les pme fasse faillite s'est en
revanche d'augmenter le smic net en
baissant la csg pour eva là les smicards
afin qu'on puisse revalorisé qu'est ce
que leur porte monnaie car c'est là vous
ne touchez pas les pme
vous ne les affaiblit sais pas mais en
même temps vous permettez à ceux qui ont
des bas salaires d'avoir un supplément
de salaire quand il se l'est fait ce
matin on va avancer on va avancer mais
on n'a pas les mêmes permettez-moi donc
à me temime a prévu de partir dès les
animations plus adultes 21h40 je fais
une opposition on a le même ton ferme
j'espère on a le vendredi seront très
simples on a aujourd'hui le prélèvement
à la source
jusqu'ici on ne pouvait pas faire la
fusion entre l'impôt sur le revenu et la
csg
et donc on a là c'est assez aisé
aujourd'hui c'est un lot unique
un taux qui est équivalent pour celui
qui gagne beaucoup et celui qui gagne on
peut donc si vous faites la fusion entre
l'impôt sur le revenu la csg
vous avez la possibilité de rendre
progressive la saisie des fermes
solaires faire ça mais on ne pouvait pas
le faire juste ainsi partiellement la
sont là avant ses produits c'est
possible williams arrive du coup marine
le pen non mais j'ai manqué et aller
jusqu'au bout je suis désolé mais côté
marine le pen et contre le smig merci
beaucoup au revoir on passe à autre
chose le cas pas de lancement nom de
pierre van damme fervent ce qu'on
pourrait dire non on peut augmenter les
salaires et les bas salaires sont
augmenter le smic c'est à dire sans
augmenter les charges qui pèsent sur les
ppp mais pas le medef les tpe pme les
artisans les commerçants et leur dit
vous allez au goût être obligés de payer
plus parce que vous allez payer plus de
charges non mais vous dise que tout va
mal rires voilà mais vous allez on se
rend effectivement lundi
non mais beaucoup plus à la fin je crois
pas une minute pour conclure le
déguisement c'est la c1 dames le pen
dont je parlais tout à l'heure est un
moyen extrêmement simple d'augmenter le
les bas salaires et même jusqu'à 1,6
fois le smic
très clairement très rapidement est ce
encore une fois que les entraînements
mais attendez c'est pas sérieux
quelle sécurité c'est pas sérieux c'est
pourquoi c'est beau ça on va évoquer
cette question très importante du
maintien de l'ordre
cette crise de l'autorité que nous
vivons dans notre pays et j'appelle
gérard leclerc de ces news pour vous
poser une question bonsoir gérard bon
soir après cinq mois de mouvements des
gilet jaune
selon l'ifop 46% des français
soutiennent encore ou ont de la
sympathie pour le mouvement et ça malgré
les scènes de débordement des meutes et
attaques de policiers les champs elysées
où l'arc de triomphe saccagé et puis
même les sabotages des radars auparavant
il y avait déjà eu des affrontements en
souviens de notre dame des landes la
violence régulièrement dans les
quartiers cette fois et chaque fois
c'est l'autorité de l'état donc la
république qui sont contestés dans une
société fracturée
d'autant que souvent ces violences bien
sont excusés voire légitimer par les
injustices sociales par la violence de
classe face à la répression policière
alors l'autorité donc contesté mais en
même temps et c'est le paradoxe une
demande accrue d'autorité des français
là encore selon l'ifop
72% des français font confiance à la
police 51% à la justice et selon deux
autres enquêtes 38 % des français
seraient prêts à accepter un régime
autoritaire pour réformer la france et
50% un pouvoir militaire en cas
d'attentât alors marine le pen vous vous
dénoncez l'ensauvagement de la société
temis à 57 qu'est ce que vous proposez
oui enfin vous voyez que très clairement
je ne peux pas quand même vous n'allez
pas nous faire parler ce soir
de l'insécurité en nous parlant des
casseurs dans à la fin des
manifestations des gilet jaune doit
c'est pas raisonnable c'est pas sérieux
le problème de l'insécurité règne de la
criminalité qui s'aggrave
considérablement notre dans notre pays
n'a pas attendu les gilet jaune qui
n'ont strictement rien à voir là dedans
c'est l'augmentation spectaculaire des
cambriolages c'est l'augmentation
spectaculaire dont personne ne parle des
agressions sexuelles
c'est ce sont les violences et notamment
c'est vrai un an sauvagement de la
société c'est-à-dire une aggravation de
ce qu'on appelle les crimes gratuits
en réalité depuis des années sous
taubira mais également il faut bien le
dire madame bel et bien il y a eu un
laxisme total en matière de justice
voilà c'est là la vieille rengaine de
gauche en les pauvres ils ont eu une
enfance difficile et donc il faut
comprendre et or donc on abaisse les
peines
et puis on considère qu'au bout de deux
ans de même à deux ans de condamnation
ne fera pas la prison maintenant c'est 5
ans de condamnation
on frappe à la prison etc la réalité
c'est que je suis désolé de vous le dire
en matière d'insécurité de criminalité
si on n'arrête pas les criminels ils
s'arrêteront pas et donc la première des
choses c'est de maîtriser d'abord nos
frontières la deuxième des chaussées de
rétablir l'autorité de l'état l'autorité
de la justice
l'autorité de la justice la certitude
des peines des peines qui soit
réellement un exode des lignes et de 32
pour cela et pour cela il faut toute la
chaîne pénale soit mobilisé de temps à
manille compris non pardon parce que moi
je considère que c'est fondamental et si
oui vous parce que la sécurité à minima
d'amener les libertés est engagée dès
aussi des constructions de places de
prison parce que ça fait 20 ans qu'on
nous dit qu'on va en construire on ne
construit pas et donc on libère des
criminels parce qu'on dirait il ya plus
de place non mais ce qu'elle est ce pays
comment est-il gouverner est-ce que
sérieusement vous pensez que les
français peuvent avoir confiance dans
des gouvernants qui nous disent on va
libérer des criminels et des délinquants
graves parce qu'on a plus de place dans
les prisons l'arrêt l'espace guérini non
on a évoqué cette question de crise de
l'autorité puisqu'on parlait des
violences qui ont frappé le pays ces
derniers mois vous avez eues il faut le
dire dans la majorité beaucoup de mal
définir votre doctrine de maintien de
l'ordre des hésitations des revirements
des limogeages jusqu'à la loi
anti-casseurs censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel
est-ce que vous reconnaissez ce soir
votre part d'échec dans ces violences
moi d'abord quand vous me parler de ce
sujet là j'aimerais rendre hommage à nos
forces de l'ordre parce que voulez vous
on sait on l'a vu dans le sondage on le
dit trop rarement les responsables
politiques ont parfois été trop timide
sur ce sujet là les forces de l'ordre
sont mises en cause de façon incessante
j'étais dans les banlieues dans le
commissariat
dans ma circonscription du 18ème
arrondissement à paris joyet qui avait
eu 20 officiers qui ont été blessés et
bien ce soir je souhaite rendre hommage
aux forces de l'ordre qui font un
travail remarquable
samedi après samedi et pas que les
samedis maintenant je crois qu'il faut
pas tout confondre
il ya eu au début de ce mouvement des
gilets jaunes des revendications
sociales
et puis il y a eu des casseurs des gens
qui n'étaient là pour pas faire avancer
le pays qui étaient là pour renverser le
système et cette majorité au contraire
je crois qu'elle a été l'élément de
stabilité dans le débat public où
parfois il est certain qu'il vendredi
soir était pour la défense des libertés
publiques et le dimanche soir pour le
retour de l'ordre sécuritaire nous nous
avons été constants sur ce sujet là pour
défendre l'ordre républicain
nous avons été la majorité qui a investi
dans le budget des forces de l'ordre
pour qu'on puisse embaucher
on a mis fin à une diète total de lambus
de policiers de gendarmes plus dix mille
mais il essaye de gendarmes dans le
monde
nous avons voté des lois à l'assemblée
nationale pour justement mieux lutter
contre les casseurs nous avons fait
évoluer les doctrines pour pouvoir mieux
appréhender des individus en marge des
manifestations
ça c'est la stabilité c'est comme ça
c'est qu'on doit rétablir l'ordre
quadrillent à quatre mains ce là dessus
sur cette question de la violence la
sécurité dans notre pays
vous avez remarqué comme souvent on
convoque l'ordre républicain pour faire
des injonctions au calme mais la
république ce n'est pas un régime neutre
la devise s'est pas vu ce bon pour les
frontons des mairies
c'est liberté égalité fraternité 5 166
morts dans la rue dont 13 enfants
est-ce que c'est l'ordre républicain 9
millions de pauvres dans ce pays est-ce
que c'est l'ordre républicain
500 morts par an au travail est-ce que
c'est l'ordre républicain
un agriculteur qui se suicident tous les
deux jours est-ce que c'est l'ordre
républicain
non ça n'est pas l'ordre républicain
l'ordre républicain ça n'est pas les
tirs de lanceurs de balles de défense et
les grenades de désencerclement pour
réprimer un mouvement de contestation
populaire
l'ordre républicain c'est la
souveraineté populaire bafoué depuis
2005 et que monsieur macron continue à
bafouer l'ordre républicain c'est
l'égalité devant l'impôt
c'est la justice sociale l'ordre
républicain c'est les intérêts
particuliers soumis à l'intérêt général
c'est la loi contre les privilèges c'est
la loi contre les bena la voilà ce
qu'est l'ordre républicain
alors après bien sûr moi je suis
personnellement et j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire je ne suis pas d'accord avec les
stratégies de violence en politique mais
monsieur castaner porte la
responsabilité des centaines de blessés
et des milliers blessées côté
manifestants comme côté policier par ces
pratiques et il doit normalement en
homme d'état il devrait partir il
devrait s'en aller
voilà ce qui doit être dit parce que
c'est bien lui qui porte la
responsabilité de ceux ci et je suis
persuadé d'une chose je dois le dire il
n'y a pas d'ordre public possible sans
justice sociale
par conséquent il faut d'abord apporter
la réponse politique que nos concitoyens
attendent depuis maintenant près de
quatre mois et vous portez la
responsabilité du fait que des gens
honnêtes qui venez en famille dans ces
manifestations avec le souci de
mobilisation pacifique ont fini de votre
faute par croire après quatre mois que
la violence était utile pour se faire
entendre
ça aussi c'est votre responsabilité
laurent wauquiez simplement d'un mot
pour démarrer vous demandez toujours le
retour de l'état d'urgence d'abord il ya
un point là d'avoir ma question et vous
avez du temps pour vous exprimer
ce que vous demandez toujours le retour
de l'état d'urgence non ça avait du sens
quand on était au début du mouvement
pour tout de suite ramené le calme et je
regrette que monsieur guérini ici soit
pas capable de dire qu'il ya évidemment
eu des fautes et des erreurs qui ont été
commises dans le maintien de l'or mais
c'est l'évidence la loi sur les casseurs
elle a été proposée par les républicains
vous avez mis des semaines à la reprend
vous nous auriez écouter sur l'état
d'urgence on aurait sans doute pu
arriver rétablir de l'ordre rapidement
vous venez ici en nous disant je
souhaite rendre hommage au policier ou
gendarme très bien mais commencer par
les protéger commencez par mettre en
place les mesures qui permettent de les
protéger
non
à proposer quelque chose de simple
comment voulez vous que cela puisse
fonctionner quand alors que les
policiers les gendarmes sont agressés
votre ministre de l'intérieur comme
seule parole de dire je ne veux pas une
police brutale et c'est pas la police
qui est brutale ce sont les casseurs qui
sont brutaux comment voulez vous que ça
fonctionne quand vous avez une garde des
sceaux qui explique que quand on est
condamné à six mois de prison il ne faut
pas aller en prison
comment voulez vous que ça marche comme
ça et donc moi ce que je demande c'est
que vous mettiez en place une mesure de
bon sens qui consiste à faire quoi
s'assurer que ceux qui agressent nos
policiers et nos gendarmes soient punis
avec des peines minimum planchers
exemplaires
vous feriez sens ce serait bien plus
efficace que de venir ici nous y tenir
je souhaite rendre hommage au policier
ou gendarme parce que c'est pas votre
match dont ils ont besoin c'est dont ils
ont besoin c'est votre soutien
ce dont ils ont besoin c'est votre
protection et elle leur a manqué depuis
de trop longues semaines
monsieur guérineau monsieur corman vous
êtes très en retard sur notre tendre sur
fait dire je vous remercie de rappeler
je suis un peu en retard le précise sur
le temps de parole sur la question
pardon je peux pas laisser dire que
baisser les charges comme c'était
notamment par madame le pen
les charges sociales sur les salaires ça
revient à augmenter le pouvoir d'achat
des gens parce que ça existe pas les
charges sociales ce sont des pas donc
des cotisations sociales
oui je me permets de le faire et j ai
voulu dire bref possible
je fais très bref les cotisations
sociales mais ce serait des revenus
différés et donc quand on réduit les
cotisations et à serge et en appelant sa
des charges sociales c'est une
conséquence simple c'est notamment la
situation des personnes âgées qui n'ont
plus les moyens d'avoir accès à des
ehpad publics et qui se retrouvent à
l'être dans difficulté s'est rappelé la
question quelque chose qui m'interpelle
vous savez dans le champ lexical et dans
la façon dont les personnalités
politiques nomme les choses on ait parlé
on est passé des gardiens de la paix aux
forces de l'ordre et je pense que c'est
très significatif d'un glissement
provisoire ou pendant longtemps il y
avait un compromis social qui permettait
d'avoir des débats et les choses soient
apaisées aujourd'hui ce à quoi on
assiste c'est une brutalisation du débat
c'est une forme de morgue du pouvoir
actuel savez comment c'est un petit peu
avant ou
gens se sentent à juste titre humilié
nié dans leur dignité et se manifeste
comme ils ont raison de le faire
et la réponse du pouvoir c'est des
réponses à côté de la plaque sur le fond
est une doctrine du maintien de en fait
je voudrais j'aimerais dire un mot
là-dessus parce que il ya d'autres
façons pour maintenir l'ordre
il ya d'autres doctrines dans d'autres
pays européens on n'utilise pas les
ailes bd on n'utilise pas les grenades
de désencerclement et su retourner une
stratégie d'aller vers les manifestants
pour repérer celles et ceux qui
souhaitent effectivement dans leur mode
militance agir avec violence
la doctrine du maintien de l'ordre en
france n'est pas celle là la doctrine du
maintien de rendre en france
c'est de considérer les manifestantes et
les manifestants comme une foule
uniforme qu'on maltraite parce qu'on
veut éteindre la manifestation qui sont
en train de fait et là des responsables
se sont pas les policiers
les responsables ce sont bien celles et
ceux qui donnent des ordres dont
aujourd'hui effectivement le ministre de
l'intérieur tant qu'on ne sortira pas de
cette logique
ce lien de lien de confiance avec les
citoyens à des citoyens qu'on lui
considère au fond comme une menace
possible par rapport au pouvoir tant qu
on fonctionnera de cette façon là on
n'aurait pas une société apaisée
or dans une démocratie la nécessité
absolue si on veut une démocratie
vivante c'est l'apaisement des débats
mais comment vous ne pensez pas aussi
qu'en reculant notre dame des landes
très précisément gouvernement a validé
la violence de certains à 10 et de
certains black blocks et moi c'est qu'on
a retrouvés dans les rues par non mais
c'est quoi le rapport avec la choucroute
sarsan vie le début notre nom mais ces
lycées intéressantes sur les diablotins
parce que dans la doctrine actuelle on
assimile effectivement les manifestants
écologistes avec les régionalistes avec
les terroristes
c'est la même procédure qui applique à
tous ces gens moi je pense que les
militants écologistes qui militent à
notre dame des landes depuis des
décennies de façon absolument paisible
ont toujours demandé à ce qu'il y ait
une analyse pluriel des façons de voir
le projet notre amazigh nommé lentilles
militants je pense que la grande
majorité des militants étaient gentils
oui la malle de recruter des militants
où j'étais légèrement notre dame
charmant un repas bilal vouziers
terriblement charmant mais j'y suis
aller militer d'abord avec les caches
d'armes et où charmant
il est question david intéressant oui
messieurs de matinée françois hollande
oui il y avait des caches d'armes à
notre dame des landes oui et ils ont été
agressés avec des armes effectivement il
s'est blessé mais chez moi les armes
donc permettez moi de vous dire que moi
je veux bien vous nous expliquer qu'il
s'agissait de militants qui étaient avec
des petites fleurs et tout il y avait eu
lieu en avait surnombre
non mais plutôt de mépriser du fjord
avait sûrement important le mais très
honnêtement il y avait aussi des
anarchistes qui venait partiellement de
france d'ailleurs qui venait aussi d'un
certain nombre de pays qui utilisent ce
que sous-entend la technique des black
blocks ont étudié tous les samedi à
paris contre les forces de l'ordre
amalgamerait ce qu'on appellerait ne
nous convient de regarder la paille en
fin vous mêlant la violence du côté de
vos amis dont je vois ce qui s'est passé
à christ church ses cd avec des arbres
avec des vraies armes faisait passer les
tories au moment où ils étaient les
auris est un rite niveau m'a d'ailleurs
en fait les théories vous développer ses
pertes à votre niveau en effet les
délais thyroïde que vous développez sur
le grand remplacement
c'est effectivement une forme de
violence et quand monsieur bild votre
ancien conseiller politique évoquée le
terrorisme comme une opportunité pour
vous en matière électorale en 2017
qu'est ce que vous croyez vous voulez
gagner je peux citer la petite phrase
qu'il a visionné à l'époque c'est très
intéressant et bruno bilde avec le
terrorisme on ne sait pas quels
événements peuvent encore intervenir et
donc dans quel état d'esprit sera le
peuple français d'ici à avril 2017
on peut avoir une bonne surprise une
bonne surprise madame le pen pour parler
d'hypothèses d'un acte déroulement et
vous avez le plus écologiste a nommé un
conseil va vu tour vous servira toute
votre carrière politique ne croit
conseil nicolas dépanner rendez vous
conseille nicola spirig pouvait parler
peut-être de la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens je suis un élu de banlieue
on a beaucoup parlé police au moment des
manifestations
d'abord je voudrais dire que si on
respectait les forces de l'ordre on
paierait leurs heures supplémentaires
est ce que vous réalisez que dans notre
pays des policiers des gendarmes qui
surtout les policiers qui n'en peuvent
plus qui sont insultés et agressés et
pas sur les champs elysées une fois par
semaine au quotidien depuis des années
eux ne sont toujours pas payés par leur
part l'état de leurs heures
supplémentaires millions c'est un
problème d'abord de respect pour cette
profession le second point s'il vous
plaît ce genre et que la règle est la
même pour le second point
c est ce qu on peut s'occuper de la
sécurité au quotidien et la sécurité au
quotidien c'est le laxisme judiciaire
absolument inimaginable qui fait que des
personnalités j'en ai eu dans ma ville
condamné à plusieurs reprises pour
trafic de drogue ne font pas de peine de
prison ça commence et malheureusement
est à loi dati deux ans après la loi
taubira et s'est toujours appliqué
pareil l'état de nos prisons est
dramatique les surveillants
pénitentiaires sont ne sont pas
soutenues la seule préoccupation de
madame belloubet c'est de mettre le
téléphone dans les cellules et d'aller
faire des cours pour inciter les détenus
à voter oui parce que aux européennes
c'est la première fois que les détenus
ont des incitations par le garde des
sceaux de voter les honnêtes gens
on s'en occupe pas les victimes mais les
détenus les voyous le gouvernement est
auprès d'eux c'est inadmissible que ça
puisse voter les détenus oui ça me
choque mais aussi parce que quand on a
eu viol et la loi républicaine
j'estime qu'on doit le payer et il ya un
moment dans notre pays s'il ya autant
d'insécurité
d'ailleurs c'était le cas jusqu'à une
loi qui est revenu dessus
si dans notre pays il ya autant
d'insécurité et on le voit au quotidien
c'est parce que un trafiquant de drogue
arrêté quinze fois n'aura pas la peine
de prison qui le dissuadera de continuer
le deuxième point sur lequel je vais
insister et je pense que j'ai un peu de
retard j'ai pas être trop long rassurez
vous c'est le contrôle des frontières
on parle tout le temps du contrôle des
frontières uniquement pour l'immigration
oui mais on n'en parle pas pour le
trafic d'armes pour le trafic de drogue
pour la surveillance des mouvements et
les terroristes qu'on a eu
malheureusement dans notre pays on
circuler librement dans toute l'europe
donc il faut à la fois qu'on est une
institution judiciaire beaucoup plus
ferme des peines de prison appliqués et
puis des contrôles des frontières pour
lutter contre les mafias qui se sont
implantés au fur et à mesure du temps
dans notre pays qui redouble d'intensité
l'ordre républicain
c'est tout simplement l'ordre juste
ceux qui aujourd'hui manque
singulièrement c'est effectivement la
justice et tout ce qu'on peut reprocher
ce gouvernement c'est d'avoir à chercher
non pas à répondre à la demande de
justice mais d'avoir organisé semaine
après semaine
un face à face entre les casseurs et le
gouvernement ne jamais avoir cherché à
rétablir les conditions d'un dialogue
les conditions d'un dialogue
c'était ce qu'il fallait faire
évidemment au lieu de quoi nous avons eu
d'abord ce face à face puis un débat
qu'on a baptisée grand débat qui s'était
enlisé où le chef de l'état a beaucoup
pris la parole mais en réalité peu
écoutés et le problème dans ces cas là
c'est que la colère elle monte la colère
elle va plus fort chaque jour et c'est
toute la difficulté aujourd'hui parce
que ce gouvernement a tout fait faux
d'abord il a répondu tard et il a
répondu uniquement sous la pression sous
la pression y compris de la destruction
par les casseurs et donc il s'était
établi une équivalence a peut-être des
gens que la casse pouvait effectivement
rapporté
j'étais sur les ronds-points dans ma
circonscription ce qui le monde y était
terrible ils m'ont dit vous vous rendez
compte monsieur le député on vous aime
bien mais le problème c'est que quand
vous vous déposer des amendements à
l'assemblée
est ce que vous êtes vraiment entendu
est ce que les syndicats sont vraiment
entendu nous on a effectivement été se
rendre dans une médiation avec des
casseurs et bien les casseurs sat
amicaux à 10 milliards sur la table et
c'est cette équivalence là qui est folle
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
évidemment rétablir un dialogue avec
toutes ces organisations intermédiaires
pour faire en sorte qu'il y ait à
nouveau de la médiation qu'on puisse à
nouveau se parler dans ce pays et faire
en sorte qu'il y ait du dialogue social
mais à écouter c'est comme important
dialogue social on peut pas non plus le
balayer d'un revers de la main comme ça
en une seconde
ce qui manque singulièrement à ce
gouvernement quand vous pensez qu'il ya
aujourd'hui 19 organisations qui sont
venus présenter au gouvernement et un
centre des français un projet sur le
pouvoir de vivre en cela vous regarde ce
nom mais non je voudrais pas de
suppléant
l'ordre public sa corrèze mais parce que
vous pensez que même nicolas hulot qui a
présenté ce document avec avec laurent
bergé ancien ministre de ce gouvernement
qu'il n'est même pas reçu même pas
entendu même pas écouté mais que faut-il
faire pour que enfin ils comprennent que
la colère elle naît du fait que passer
entendu ce message est passé
l'invention non non sur ceux gérés
exclusivement mermoz j'aimerais qu'on
fasse juste une pause d'une seconde
parce que c'est toujours la même chose
dans ce type de débat
je suis accusé à ma droite d'être trop
laxiste
les mêmes qui ont supprimé 13 mille
postes de policiers dans le mandat de
nicolas sarkozy
c'est vrai et puis à la gauche d'être au
final trop autoritaire alors même que
nous avons apporté des réponses mais
quelle raison quel gouvernement
quel gouvernement a pris en un mois de
temps la décision de la porter de 10
milliards d'euros de réponse vous en
aviez pris pas moins sous la pression
alors avancé la pression la pression
vicieux madame encore les caricatures de
leurs embauches et une avance nous il
est 22 heures passées les français nous
regardent certains vont même aller
travailler demain matin je voudrais
qu'on avance sur ces questions qui vous
concerne aussi vous allez pouvoir
répondre l'identité française ou plus
violentes chez lui 13 laurent wauquiez a
retiré la suite de ce qu'a dit monsieur
guérini très intéressant et ça prendra
dix secondes monsieur guérini je
convaincs force de tout faire en même
temps la bonne leçon pour vous ce soir
c'est qu'en réalité vous le faites rire
et cette leçon là vous devriez ne pas
l'oublier
voilà voilà beaucoup de violences y
compris sur ce plateau d'une certaine
manière vous leur écoute ça va ça va ça
va c'est pas exagérer le vide occasion
fait passer un bon moment
notre région vous êtes content de vous
retrouver à ça arrive une fois de temps
en temps bon y at il un problème
d'identité en france nous vous posons la
question ce soir est ce qu on sait où on
va et ce qu'on y va ensemble
alors d'abord un petit tour de table
qu'est-ce qu'être français aujourd'hui
nous tenions à vous poser la question
quelle france dans quelle europe
que l'on soit des ronds-points ou des
centres-villes sommes-nous ego que l'on
soit à paris ou à bourg-en-bresse à vos
yeux qu'est ce qu'être français
aujourd'hui en une minute david cormand
être français c'est la république et les
valeurs de la république liberté égalité
fraternité ça se résume en armant la
justice et aujourd'hui je crois que la
république doit renouveler ses voeux par
rapport à cette promesse originelle et
renouveler ses voeux c'est mettre au
coeur de son projet les communs depuis
tout à l'heure on a parlé d
individualisme des individualités des
conflits qualité dans la société pour
refaire société pour refaire nation
c'était votre question il faut la
république il faut la république des
communs là je crois aussi que c'est
adhérer à notre devise républicaine la
liberté l'égalité et la fraternité mais
de faire en sorte que cette devise là il
ne soit pas simplement inscrits sur les
frontons de nos mairies que la liberté
et l'égalité soit une égalité réelle
d'un pays et c'est ce à quoi nous
attachons depuis le début de ce mandat
faire en sorte que trop souvent les
droits formels les droits concrets les
droits qu'on vote à l'assemblée
nationale et puissent devenir des droits
réels de faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus
de mobilité dans notre société que on
met plus - que six générations à se
sortir de la pauvreté
là nous rendrons réel la promesse
républicaine française qui est celle de
la liberté de l'égalité et la fraternité
laurent wauquiez qu'est ce qu'être
français aujourd'hui à vos yeux les
belles votre question elle doit être
d'abord ans
oui madame ferrari nous permettent de
vous le dire quelque chose ça vous voyez
c'est toute la déchéance de ce qu'est
devenu notre débat médiatique et
politique
on vous pose une question magnifique
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être français qui
méritera un livre de marc bloch qui
mériteraient qu'on revisite la vis et
vous nous dites vous avez une minute
pour répondre vous rendez compte de ce
qu'est devenu nos débats quelle
tristesse et calmez vous en êtes
capables alors j'ai quand même essayé de
vous répondre qu'est ce que c'est c'est
d'être à bord les héritiers d'une
histoire qui est magnifique c'est ça et
de français 7 les héritiers de la
fontaine 7 les héritiers de notre
histoire de l'histoire d'un pays qui a
su se forger dans la résistance dont
l'affrontement avec ceux qui étaient
autour de nous qui petit à petit édifié
quoi une civilisation unique qu'est
l'héritière de trois traditions notre
tradition judéo-chrétienne celles de
l'humanisme la tradition de l'antiquité
et la tradition des lumières on est le
point d'aboutissement de tout ça et ce
qui parfois me fait rager
c'est le sentiment qu'on donne d'avoir
honte
de ce que nous sommes de ne plus assumer
notre fierté de ne plus la transmettre
d'avoir petit à petit laissé s'installer
au nom de je sais quel droit à la
différence le fait que maintenant celui
qui vient chez nous n'a plus à coeur
d'adopter notre identité mais de
contester notre mode de vie
c'est ça ce qui me rend triste je pense
qu'on a une histoire magnifique une
culture magnifique et que la plus belle
des générosités
c'est de la transmettre à ceux qui
viennent derrière nous c'est ça être
français adria qu'un tenace qu'est ce
que c'est pour vous qu'être français
la république font dans la nation être
français selon moi c'est se sentir
universel et faire vivre pour soi et
pour le collectif
la devise est lui de décors
politiquement liberté égalité fraternité
c'est un contenu politique être français
c'est aussi avoir une part de
souveraineté laquelle je les dis a été
trop souvent bafouée raison pour
laquelle quand une majorité de français
70% sont favorables référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et qu'une
nouvelle fois monsieur guérini se trouve
en minorité je suis du côté de cette
majorité
je crois aussi que l'impasse dans
laquelle nous sommes faits urgence à
nous refonder comme peuple et pour
refaire peuple
je le crois il est temps de passer à la
6ème république et pour ce faire de
convoquer une assemblée citoyenne
constituante corps est en charge de se
redéfinir de redéfinir quel droit nous
nous reconnaissons les uns les autres
afin de refaire peuple tous ensemble
voilà ce que je pense qu'être français
marine le pen qu'est ce qu'être français
un trans ss c'est un acte d'amour voilà
tout simplement pourquoi vous aimez
votre femme quand vous aimez votre pari
c'est aimer aimer effectivement
l'histoire et mais ce patrimoine
matériel et immatériel carrière les deux
notre patrimoine matériel et immatériel
c'est aimer la liberté y compris celle
des femmes qui est en train de
disparaître progressivement dans toute
une série d'endroits en france dans
toutes les séries de quartier c'est mais
le débat s'est aimé l'idée c'était avoir
les mêmes codes les mêmes moeurs et vous
savez il ya beaucoup de français
d'ailleurs d'origine étrangère qui se
sentent profondément français parce que
ils ont cet acte d'amour à l'égard de la
france ils l'ont choisi
moi ce que j'arrive pas à comprendre de
la part de certains qui arrivent
aujourd'hui c'est que il arrive
aujourd'hui en france en réalité pour la
changer
il veut lui imposer leurs codes leurs
moeurs leurs traditions leur mode de vie
et bien moi je le redis avec ça ça va
pas être possible voilà soit vous venez
parce que vous aimez la france vous
faites cet acte d'amour et vous
l'apprenez et vous vous soumettez ou
alors vous voulez rester ce que vous
êtes et à ce moment là je vous suggère
vivement dresser leur pays d'origine
olivier faur la france c'est bientôt et
bien sûr aimer la france et aimer sa
géographie et met sa culture
mais son histoire bien sûr mais depuis
la révolution française c'est plus que
cela c'est adhésion à des valeurs celles
qui ont été rappelés liberté égalité
fraternité et auxquels il faut ajouter
laïcité c'est ça la france et je réponds
à madame l'open qui voudraient comme
toujours nous expliquait qu' il y aurait
des français quitteraient
indéfectiblement français parce que de
souche je sois même eurasien là je suis
je suis razia et donc ma mère est née à
quelques milliers de kilomètres d'ici
elle est venue parce qu'elle était dans
un pays qui était un pays en guerre et
elle se sent aujourd'hui française et à
la respecte à la fois la culture mais
elle sait aussi d'où elle vient et elle
sait aussi que sa culture n'est pas une
culture qui ne peut pas enrichir ce pays
dans lequel nous sommes est donc voila
moi j'aimerais un pays ouvert
impy flanelle un pays où on ne se
replient par en permanence on n'est pas
comme vous l'êtes sur une forme de cette
entité d'identité racine au nom de
filles fermées dans des terrasses il
aurait cette façon de considérer que
celui qui arrivent et forcément non pas
un apport non pas une richesse mais
toujours un problème
la tête de ghilas que jordan barre des
late ruines on dit que la vie alors pour
lui que la durée alors et alors c'est
qu'on sait bien que c'est pas votre
problème n'est pas l'italie
j'ai même aujourd'hui avec eux salvini
votre problème il est ailleurs on le
sait bien
les portugais avec les écouteurs
je crois qu'il y avait une belle phrase
d'andré malraux qui disait qu être
français c'est accepter de mourir pour
son pays sans se poser de questions
parce que c'est comme pour ses enfants
si nos enfants - danger vous précipitez
voulait sauver vous réfléchissez pas
même autrui
être français c'est donc mourir pour son
pays quand je me sens bénie est en
danger être français c'est aussi un bloc
on choisit pas on choisit pas les
périodes de son histoire
on comprend la france telle qu'elle
s'est forgée puis avec des racines
gréco-latine une histoire
judéo-chrétienne le siècle des lumières
c'est un ensemble et on sépare pas on
choisit pas c'est un bloc comme disait
clemenceau là c'était sur la révolution
c'était pas sur la france mais
qu'importe
et puis il ya un autre point qui qui me
paraît très important
être français c'est aussi une dynamique
pourquoi beaucoup de jeunes français ou
de gens qui sont arrivés sur notre sol
ne s'assimile pas c'est peut-être aussi
parce que les français de souche ont
perdu la fierté de la france
la volonté de la défendre et de la
rendre libre c'est être français c'est
col.red français c'est être libre libre
fort justes et le problème de son
aujourd'hui pourquoi il ya une crise
d'identité il ya une crise existentielle
c'est parce que nos dirigeants ont donné
les clés de la maison france à des
technocrates non élu à des marchés
financiers et que les français voient
bien qu'ils n'ont plus le pouvoir donc
on pourra retrouver notre idée telle
identité française que lorsque les
français retrouveront le pouvoir de
maîtriser leur destin
c'est ça l'enjeu est majeur allez on va
parler maintenant toujours d'identité
française mais aussi de laïcité vous
l'avez évoqué avec gérard leclerc de ces
news est rare
revenez à la table allez-y pour votre
question est oui parce qu'effectivement
on l'a dit la république c'est la
liberté l'égalité la fraternité mais
c'est aussi la laïcité avec la loi de
1905 sur la séparation de l'église et de
l'état et la liberté de conscience
mais une liberté que beaucoup voient eux
menacés par l'islam radical et les
communautés
is me gérard collomb on s'en souvient en
quittant le ministère de l'intérieur
alertés sur les quartiers dégradés ou
est-il dit s'impose de plus en plus la
loi du plus fort notamment des
islamistes radicaux
avec la crainte que demain on ne vivent
plus côte à côte mais face à face alors
le sujet est sensible a encore récemment
les propos approximatifs du président
macron sur l'absence d'interdiction du
port du voile au travail et biens a créé
la polémique mais surtout la
modification de la loi 1905 pour
l'adapter aux pratiques de l'islam qui
inquiète le gouvernement veut assurer un
financement transparent aujourd'hui il
est souvent étrangers en facilitant par
exemple l'investissement dans
l'immobilier il veut aussi lutter contre
le radicalisme par la formation d'imams
en france mais les partisans de la
laïcité et bien craignent une sorte de
concordat avec l'islam est en tout cas
que tout cela porte atteinte à cette loi
de 1905 merci gérard leclerc stanislas
guérini oui ou non est ce que vous
voulez toucher à la loi de 1905 sur la
laïcité ou non à titre personnel je ne
soutiens personne morale est d'ailleurs
la seule modification de la loi de 1905
nous en fait c'est pour permettre aux
actions aux associations cultuelles de
recevoir des dons par sms
je suis désolé en 1905 est pas de s m
est donc payé il a été la seule
modification
moi je ne souhaiterais pas c'est une
place colossale pour la partielle du
droit au 6 allée de la loi de 1905 sur
la laïcité est un joyau de la république
et je souhaite que on applique la loi de
1905 et toute la loi de 1905 parce que
cette loi c'est une loi de liberté de
liberté de croire ou de ne pas croire et
je ne suis pas du côté qui souhaitent
ceux qui souhaitent faire de cette loi
une arme contre les religions et je
crois que nous devons chérir et pas tout
c'est la ligne la république est en
marche
en tout cas c'est la position que
j'exprime très clairement un sujet qui
créent et qui crée du débat ça nous
aidera
mais public en mars ça nous intéresse
aussi sa maison de la république c'est
le président l'a refait il ya quelques
jours vous avez que je suis je suis tout
à fait en adhésion avec ce qu'a exprimé
le président de la république qui n'est
pas différent de ce que je viens
d'exprimer la loi de laïcité c'est une
loi de liberté
ça ne peut pas être une loi contre les
religions marine le pen on ne touche pas
à la loi de 1905
non mais évidemment qu'on n'y touche pas
enfin pardon alors non je trouve que
c'est pas très clair monsieur gainey
parce que vous savez très bien nommé
écouter on ne touche pas à ça on va pas
se raconter d'histoire vous savez très
bien que président de la république a
engagé mission pour toucher à la loi de
1905 pour permettre le développement
évidemment d'un islam dont je considère
que cette année slam politique et qu'il
est éminemment dangereux pour l'unité de
notre pays donc clairement j'ai eu
l'occasion de lui dire d'ailleurs quand
je les ai rencontrés ne touchez pas à la
loi de 10,9 travail et tout semblait une
évidence inventé grand léjon c'est la
loi de 1905 la paix que la laïcité elle
est sacrée encore faut-il que elle
trouve une expression dans le pays parce
que pour l'instant dans tous les
quartiers en france aujourd'hui la
laïcité elle ne cesse de reculer et le
gouvernement ne fait strictement rien
contre cela ni le vote ni celui qui le
précédait d'ailleurs ni celui d'avant ça
fait des années et des années qu'on
ferme les yeux en disant on va regarder
ailleurs
on va regarder ailleurs les les gens qui
me sont persécutés pour surmenage de
religion et en attendant regardez
ailleurs les fondamentalistes islamistes
qui tiennent en un des quartiers entiers
on va regarder ailleurs les femmes qui
se voient imposer tel ou tel
accoutrement ou qui sont violentées ou
insulter parce que précisément elle
refuse merci mais un tel accoutrement
alors je vais vous dire une chose tient
bien un combat qu'il faut mener
aujourd'hui et de manière urgente c'est
celui du rétablissement de la laïcité
dans notre pays mais ça ne servira à
rien si vous continuez évidemment a
laissé une submersion migratoire
elle se déverse en parler à bâle
d'abord la première chose je sais pas ce
que veut dire quand monsieur guérini
viens ici en nous disant à titre
personnel puisque tout le monde sait que
la réalité c'est que d'un travail qui
avait partagé par le président de la
république et par le gouvernement
consistant à revoir la loi de 1905
deuxième élément le sujet c'est pas
monsieur guérini de la mettre sur
étagère la loi de 1905
le sujet c'est de la protégée par des
actions concrètes
je me suis rendu très récemment dans une
école qui accueille des enfants juifs la
réalité de ce que vivent aujourd'hui nos
compatriotes juifs dans l'antisémitisme
ordinaire dans une ville comme
villeurbanne où ils ne peuvent pas
sortir pour aller pratiquer une activité
sportive ou culturelle sans se faire
traiter de sale juif au point où juste
l'école a renoncé à faire ses sorties ça
c'est la vie quotidienne voulait revenir
dessus
j'ai trois propositions et sur lesquels
je souhaiterais rapidement pouvoir
détailler la première chose d'abord il
faut fermer les mosquées salafistes
il ya cent mosquées salafistes en france
aucune décision n'a été prise en la
matière il faut fermer ces mosquées qui
presley la deuxième chose on a des
fichiers est dans notre pays qui sont
suivis pour radicalisation une partie
d'entre eux sont étrangers je ne
comprends pas ce qu'attend le
gouvernement pour expulser au moins hors
de france les étrangers qui sont
fichiers et puis la troisième chose d'un
sujet quand même qu'il ya beaucoup
interpellé les français c'est la
question des jihadistes la garde des
sceaux contrairement à ce qui avait été
dit initialement a fini par reconnaître
que le gouvernement avait fait revenir
sur le sol français 200 qui a distrait 1
200 jihadistes nous ce que nous
demandons c'est que les djihadistes
soient jugés condamnés et restent en
irak et en syrie
ce que nous proposons c'est qu' un
tribunal pénal qui soit installée en
irak
à l'image de ce qui s'était passé à
nuremberg et qui permettent de les juger
et qu'ils restent en irak
je ne peux pas comprendre qu'on puisse
prendre le risque qu'on puisse prendre
le risque de faire rentrer sur le sol
français des djihadistes c'est quoi le
rapport avec lui monsieur vous avez un
seul doute sur le fait que les
djihadistes prêche autre chose que la
destruction
zéro rist vous poser des risques là
dessus vous parlez de n'avait aucun
doute là dessus
décidément votre aveuglement finit par
l'impressionnisme un peu plus l'idée
fort sur cette question de laïcité
j'avoue que de l'esprit français a dit
social de l'esprit français parce que
c'est la seule façon de concilier à la
fois la liberté de croire ou de ne pas
croire
l'égalité entre ceux qui croient et ceux
qui ne croient pas et puis de préserver
la cohésion entre les uns et les autres
et donc c'est un un bien précieux qu'on
était qu'on ne doit toucher à aucun prix
et c'est vrai que je suis très surpris
ce soir pendant monsieur guérini nous
dira qu' ils ne veulent pas y toucher il
y a une mission qui a été lancé on a
tous compris qu'il y avait dans des
travaux préparatoires et donc c'est une
bonne nouvelle que vous nous annoncez ce
soir en nous disant que rien ne sera
fait si c'est bien une bonne nouvelle
mais confirmé nous encore une fois
demandé son lancement
non mais vous allez lui à répondre
pleinement aux gachères 1905
le sud touché au financement des
finances monsieur guérini forte affirmé
mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
confirmer tout simplement que vous ne
toucherez pas mais à cette loi n'est
donnée qui est d'aucune loi fondamentale
vers vous et m mais nous allons jouer
une question cette fois de la touche pas
là mais je prépare ma réponse parce que
j'aimerais comprendre au nom de qui et
pourquoi monsieur guérini parle parce
que il y a un gouvernement qui
visiblement est hors contrôle monsieur
guérini ça peut lui échapper et donc
j'aimerais comprendre si ce qu'il s'est
dit exclue langage lui tout seul engage
son parti ou engage aussi le meilleur
moment on sache qu'à se passer je crois
est ce que vous allez ce qu'on fait nous
voulons c'est de voir la vie politique
effectivement pour savoir quand même
temps que vous je vois là et pas depuis
un mouvement la république en marche que
je représente aujourd'hui et donc je
manque c'est la ligne de l'art et bruno
marche
au nom donc ce n'est pas la ligne 20
novembre elle en veut et 7 chez donner
des leçons
non pas d'accord j'ai moi est ce qu'on
faisait qu'en marge de la loi de 1907 en
clair du tout mais c'est frais au nom la
république omar bongo ne souhaite pas
que l'on touche il ya ce qu'est d'autres
nicolas dupont-aignan sur les quatre
afghans et c'est un autre
moi je trouve sa vague en ce débat parce
que c'est vrai que c'est très important
il faut absolument respecter la loi de
mais elle n'est pas respectée au
quotidien le communautarisme est le
contraire de l'assimilation républicaine
alors on peut discuter des heures sur la
loi devient 105 moi je remarque quoi je
remarque au quotidien depuis des années
les islamistes radicaux
les salafistes un filtre nos banlieues
eux menacent les filles qui ne porte pas
le voile eux le s'étendent que l'argent
coule à flots coule à flot du golfe pour
renforcer des mosquées salafistes et
renforcer des mosquées intégristes et
que face à ça on se ferme en ferme les
yeux
combien de maires notamment locaux ont
fermé les yeux notamment seine saint
denis
ne sont pas soutenues d'ailleurs par
l'état quand ils veulent résister et
derrière cela y à quoi il ya la vie des
femmes qui devient un enfer dans
certains quartiers
laurent wauquiez avait tout à fait
raison de parler de la situation de nos
compatriotes juifs qui vivent aussi un
enfer et qui partent donc c'est très
sympathique les grandes discussions loi
1905 palois 10 905 la réalité c'est
qu'on a cédé face à des salafistes
on a cédé à face à des intégristes et
parce qu'on a une sorte de complexe
complètement ridicule et je peux vous
dire que dans ma circonscription il ya
beaucoup de français d'origine étrangère
ce sont les premiers qui viennent me
dire mais pourquoi la france est si
faible
pourquoi nous qui avons fui l'algérie
cavs ont fui des pays où il ya un
islamisme radical qui qui nous déplaît
pourquoi quand on arrive en france on va
être obligé peut-être de partir aussi de
france donc c'est pas la question des
français récents au moins récents etc
c'est la question de savoir si on veut
défendre nos valeurs et si on va
expulser les imams mais pas en expulser
trois ou quatre tous les trois ans c'est
vraiment expulser tous les imams tous
qui tous les imams qui sont qui prêche
des discours de haine
est ce qu'il est normal par exemple qu'à
strasbourg la turquie finance une des
plus grande mosquée d'europe
est ce qu'on continue comme ça voilà la
question saint adrien derrière et tenace
je crois que l'arsenal législatif permet
de solutionner un certain nombre des
problèmes qui ont été soulevés mais que
puisque votre question porte sur la
laïcité a priori il me revient de la
réhabiliter pour ce qu'elle est vraiment
à dire pas une affaire de religion
et puis d'ailleurs il ya certes un débat
dans la société française qui prennent
beaucoup plus de deux places dans la
sphère médiatico-politique que la
réalité qu'il représente dans la société
voyez-vous la religion 60% des français
ne se reconnaissent aucune et la
première chose qui nous disent en
général c'est fichez nous la paix mettez
la à distance de la plupart de vos
débats maintenant la des plans d
certains de calais ici venez dans
certaines mais quartier vous verrez bien
mais on peut en parler mais c'était là
le cadre qui ne posait la question est
celle de la laïcité la laïcité qu'est ce
que c'est devez le savoir c'est aux
jolies filles aux jeunes filles qui peut
elle a ici des anges et la laïcité
la laïcité c'est un principe qui fonde
la république une et indivisible et sa
garantie à tout membre de la société
français ou étrangers un certain nombre
de droits inaliénables d'abord ça a été
dit la liberté de conscience et donc de
culte ensuite l'égalité des droits sans
aucune discrimination
ces contenus dans la laïcité est
également la dévolution de la puissance
publique à l'intérêt général voilà ça
fait l'ensemble de la laïcité qui n'est
pas une affaire de religion alors
maintenant je vais vous dire une chose
aussi à faire c'est que une chose la loi
de 1905
oui et rien que la loi de 1905 qui met
précisément à distance la religion de la
sphère publique de manière à éviter que
nos débats politiques et nos
délibérations ne soit finalement pris
d'assaut par les vérités révélées que
personne ici ne pourrait raisonnablement
discuter mais je voudrais terminer en
disant que la laïcité du coup ne peut
pas non plus être à géométrie variable
et qu'en la matière nous avons notamment
sur ce plateau quelques tartuffe de la
laïcité parce que quand monsieur macron
s'en va dire dans un monastère je crois
que le lien entre l'église et l'état a
été abîmée alors que précisément il a
été rompu et qu'ils acceptent le titre
de curé d'honneur du pape chanoine de
latran
c'est un coup de canif portait la
laïcité quand monsieur françois hollande
président de la république déclare que
la république tous deux reconnaissent
que la république silencieux l'arrêter
leak que la république reconnaît tous
les cultes alors que précisément la loi
de 1905 dit que la république ne salarie
ne reconnaît ni ne subventionne aucun
culte c'est un coup de canif contre
laïcité à la même manière l'obsession
anti immigration de madame le pen n'est
pas la laïcité d'aller normand moi c'est
été dit par tous et on a la chance
d'avoir cette loi de 1905
d'ailleurs qui nous est enviée par un
certain nombre d'autres pays parce que
ce terme de laïcité c'est une
spécificité française et donc moi je
suive
effectivement pour la loi de 1905 toute
la loi de 1905
rien que la loi de 1905 mais ce qui est
intéressant dans nos échanges c'est
qu'en partant de cette question qui est
une question où la france sur ce point
précisément est plutôt en avance on voit
les fantasmes et les turpitudes que cela
révèle et que sera la relève
quand j'entends monsieur dupont-aignan
quand il la république tout à l'heure en
disant il faut être
il faut être prêt à mourir pour la
france mais monsieur dupont-aignan
beaucoup de personnes qui n'avaient
d'ailleurs pas demandé à être françaises
et aux français en l'occurrence son bord
pour l'info ne se fait sans être pour
autant heureux autre chose que musulman
ou et je n'ai jamais je n'ai jamais nié
le sujet le sujet à jamais la question
manqué d'un rien la question qui est
derrière
c'est la question de l'identité lya deux
représentations l'identité autour de
cette table qui a la vision d'une
identité française qui serait immuable
date et pré révolution française
d'ailleurs quand j'entends les
références de monsieur wauquiez et une
autre vision de la france aux états unis
et une autre la vision d'amd est une
autre vision de la france et de
l'identité française qui effectivement
quelque chose qui bouge qui changent en
fonction des échanges qui se font il
faut pas voir ça comme une menace
français il faut voir comme ça comme une
je peux poser une question et fait rire
le front line héberge déjà fait sur le
foll est cela le regarde et l'identité
française à laquelle moi je crois et qui
est compatible avec audrey poser une
question c'est peut toujours améliorer
l'augmentation des droits humains
toujours améliorer les droits humains
renforcer ses droits demain et quand je
vois aujourd'hui qu'en europe et
notamment la tête de liste de monsieur
vos qui remettent en question un certain
nombre de ces droits humains je pense
notamment à au droit à l'image et pour
les femmes c'est quelque chose qui me
choque et la menace
sur l'identité française la vraie menace
qui pèse sur notre pays c'est la remise
en question de ses valeurs et c'est ça
la menace qui me mois mais sera le plus
plus que les fantasmes on va passer des
dossiers clés de ce scrutin européen la
question de l'immigration qui voit
s'affronter deux visions en europe
l'europe forteresse en un jour le relais
ouverte vous comment se pose et menteuse
sur cette question on va faire le point
tout de suite sur des chiffres avec ce
court sujet guillemette à l'art avec
isabelle ory non le franchement dans
l'union européenne nous sommes plus de
512 millions d'habitants c'est 6,6 pour
cent de la population mondiale et en
france nous sommes 67 millions en 2007
plus de trois millions de personnes ont
obtenu un titre de séjour dans l'union
européenne au titre des études d'un
regroupement familial d'une demande
d'asile ou d'un emploi une sur cinq
était un demandeur d'asile venus avant
tout de pays en guerre comme la syrie
l'afghanistan ou l'irak mais aussi de
certains pays d'afrique où règne de très
fortes inégalités économiques
après la crise migratoire de 2015 2016
le nombre de demandeurs d'asile qui
arrivent via la méditerranée est
aujourd'hui en très nette baisse dans
l'union européenne
parmi les pays européens c'est
l'allemagne qui accueille le plus de
migrants avec encore plus de 160 mille
demandes d'asile en 2018
la france arrive juste derrière avec 110
mille demandes
c'est plus que l'italie la grèce ou
l'espagne la même année selon les
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur
près de vingt mille personnes en
situation irrégulière ont été expulsés
en 2013 les européens ont réformé le
système commun d'asile et d'immigration
que l'on appelle le règlement de dublin
il prévoit que dans l'essentiel des cas
c'est le pays de premières entrée qui
examine les demandes d'asile
la crise de 2015 à prouver que dublin
n'était pas adapté en cas de flux
migratoires mais les européens ne
parviennent pas à le réformer les pays
méditerranéens réclame plus de
solidarité l'est de l'europe refusent en
plus de dispositifs propres à chaque
pays en 2004 l'union européenne s'est
dotée d'une agence pour contrôler ses
frontières frontex
elle coordonne des opérations terrestres
navales et aériennes en 2018 son budget
était de 320 millions d'euros
le mois dernier les pays de l'union
européenne ont décidé de suspendre le
volet maritime de l'opération sofia
cette opération de lutte contre les
passeurs
à sauver la vie de 45000 personnes en
méditerranée depuis 2015 désormais ce
sont les garde-côtes libyens qui sont
chargés d'intercepter des candidats de
départ enfin les européens se sont aussi
dotés d'un corps de gardes-frontières
européens
ils sont mille cinq cents aujourd'hui
ils seront dix mille en 2027
naveen corman je vous ai vu réagir
pendant ce sujet ce passage est
important salon si si c'est un sujet
important mais on a déjà parlé de la
laïcité on voit bien la tentation dans
les différents débats que j'ai pu voir
d'habitude c'est la première fois que
j'ai participé à un débat de ce type que
évidemment il ya un focus qui misent sur
ce sujet moi je vous dire on va parler
de la question des migrations 5 astuces
une question fondamentale qui me tient à
coeur parce qu'elle correspond à quelle
identité qu'on veut on veut pour
l'europe
quelle quelle valeur oui et quelles
valeurs on veut pour notre continent
donc j'ai aucun problème pour y répondre
mais très franchement quand on discute
avec les gilet jaune quand on discute
d'ailleurs avec les gens qui subissent
des difficultés dans leur vie de tous
les jours ce n'est pas vrai que ce sont
ses sujets qui reviennent constamment ce
n'est pas vrai et on met un coup de
projecteur là-dessus et c'est ça qui n'a
pas pu venir mode écologique puis les
bus et des bas mais je sais on va le
faire tant mieux tant la vie de 15 ans
sur la question tant mieux tant mieux
cela est d'ailleurs essayé je
m'attendais à ce que vous disiez que
c'est lui le soient liés je vais vous
l'immigration ou non mais enfin je vous
le dirai pas dire qu'on n'a pas parlé
d'écologie c'est toujours transversale
j'ai bien compris donc on va en parler
pas de problème sur la question des
migrations ce qui est en train de se
passer aujourd'hui c'est que l'europe et
prescriptrice d'un certain nombre de
conflits de turpitudes qui pèsent sur
d'autres pays du monde
et par rapport à cette réalité c'est la
réalité du changement climatique
songez qu'au mozambique c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire du monde
il ya une ville qui a été rayé de la
carte
à cause du changement climatique quel
effet cela va avoir en matière de
migration à notre avis quand on regarde
par ailleurs vous parliez tout à l'heure
monsieur dupont-aignan des pays du golfe
qui déverse des milliards d'euros
d'après vous les millions d'euros sur
les questions du culte idée vague idée
vient surtout des milliards d'euros pour
acheter nos armes il déverse surtout des
millions d'euros pour faire de la
communication en investisseur dans le
psg et ça qu'est ce que c'est là
produisit pas facile a produit des
guerres comme au yémen qui vont
provoquer des migrations
quand on a besoin pour maintenir notre
niveau de vie en europe d'aller faire
les prédateurs par rapport aux
ressources de matières premières nous
organisons des conflits et cela crée des
migrations est donc la première chose à
faire quand on parle des migrations
c'est de se regarder dans la glace en
tant que
européens par rapport à la
responsabilité qui est la nôtre par
rapport au chaos géopolitique que nous
traversons d'abord agir agir sur les
causes et sur la question de ce qui est
en train d'arriver bien sûr qu'il faut
accueillir les migrants il faut les
accueillir j'ai envie de vous le dire le
mieux possible
pourquoi parce qu'ils peuvent être une
chance pour le continent européen toutes
ces personnes qui viennent à cause des
questions des conflits du changement
climatique ils ne viennent pas en france
parce qu'il veut le rester pour toujours
ils ne viennent pas en france comme je
l'entends parfois parce qu'il y aurait
des acquis sociaux extraordinaire ils
viennent pour ne pas mourir et la
première chose qu'ils veulent faire une
fois que le conflit ne sera plus dans
leur pays c'est de repartir
et quelle chance ce serait pour la
france et pour l'europe si nous étions
en situation de pouvoir accueillir ces
personnes dignement de les aider à
pouvoir reconstruire leur vie en sont
bien vous montez le nombre de ceux qu'on
peut accueillir et donc mes excuses à
lire dignement pardon madame laurence
ferrari mais votre question est
important de vous le dire mais me paraît
auxerre il ne faut pas laisser des gens
mourir
il ne faut pas laisser en brouillant si
les personnes sont en situation de
pouvoir mourir et qu'elle essaye de
sauver leurs enfants étaient au péril de
leur vie traverse la méditerranée dans
les conditions que l'on sait c'est
inadmissible et bien sûr qui fait rire
du poignant ce qui est quand même
tragique est paradoxal est effrayant
c'est que je ne doute pas de votre
sincérité de votre généreuse merci mais
je n'en doute pas mais que c'est ce type
de comportement d'absence de raison
d'état presse qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez des passeurs qui exploitent la
misère humaine et qui font que des
milliers de migrants se sont noyés en
méditerranée mais je vais tourner en
temps de faire une appli t il pour
l'entente regarde si je peux finir ma
face quand on regarde par exemple
l'australie qui a été d'une fermeté que
certains et que vous auriez traduit
d'inhumanité et bien réussi à bloquer
les passages et de fait il n'y a pas eu
il ya mois et a pu quasiment plus de
migrants qui se noie pour aller en
australie
ce que je veux dire c'est que est ce
qu'on ne devrait pas être donné en libye
mais c'est à dire à un moment donné
envoyer un message clair non l'europe
n'a pas les moyens avec 16 millions de
chômeurs avec des problèmes financiers
n'a pas les moyen de pomper les
richesses avion mais en vain
les bombarder monsieur je ne suis pas
pour vendre des armes à les bombarder
les gens je dis simplement que dans ce
débat au lieu de s'envoyer des anathèmes
à la figure et ce qui serait pas temps
de dire clairement
l'europe ne peut plus accueillir la
france en tout cas ne le peut pas et
dans ces conditions
détruisons les passeurs on va pas me
dire que les forces armées françaises
italiennes espagnoles ne sont pas
capables de détruire 200 organisations
de passeurs en libye
c'est pas possible deuxièmement
organisons le développement de l'afrique
et la wii par une autre politique
c'est d'ailleurs le président sénégalais
qui dit que c'est une pire la négo isc
de vouloir prendre les forces vives de
ces pays et les amener chez nous donc
moi je crois qu'il faut apaiser le débat
être d'une intransigeance absolue pour
que les migrants sache qu'il n'y aura
pas de place pour eux dans notre pays
sauf quelques cas d'asile exceptionnel
et puis parallèlement changer
complètement la politique d' aide au
développement en afrique nicolas bour
éviter le gaspillage des moyens cesse
d'enfler remy christophe castaner
ministre de l'intérieur a affirmé que
les ong en méditerranée était complice
des passeurs est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec lui quels en ont pour une
fois il a raison mais cela n'a pas
malheureusement ici l'adil allusion à
l'heureuse élue raison lui les
graphistes de salviac lemanski
d'assistance au lieu de nous prédire
n'avons qu'un seul ennemi ce sont les
réseaux de panneaux stanislas qu'il a
dit exactement il l'a d'israël a dit il
a dit que nous n'avons personnellement
je suis resté six heures il est jeune
mais vu quelqu'un les suisses en
méditerranée morgan et l'a pas dit
policière était absolument sûr
très pas ici excusez moi c'est un truc
bien le pen je vais essayer de finir
début des cas où effectivement il ya eu
des collusions qui avait été noté ces
dates et il ya trois ans un ministre de
l'intérieur italien social démocrate qui
l'avait dit ado qu'il ya eu un panier
vérité qui a été mise en place pour que
nos ong puissent faire leur travail mais
c'est quand même un dérapage faut des
erreurs cela il fallait revenir dessus
mais il faut dire les choses très
clairement nous soutenons nous soutenons
les ong qui font un travail important
dans la méditerranée aquarius le malheur
de tous à la croix yeux le faire en
sorte que les états avaient bloqué à
chaque soir ils avaient bloqué au je
vous répondrais teambuy répondez moi
vous adresserai masse que ce qu'est ce
qu'est le grand malheur il ya de
l'ambiance et de faire que les états ne
s'attaque à de prendre leurs
responsabilités élèves très aisément
trop ce récit c'est parce que oui à quoi
lui c'est faux c'est faux de dire que il
y a une possibilité d'arrêter tout flux
de personnes qui vont venir vers
l'europe il y aura encore des personnes
parce qu'elles subissent la guerre parce
qu'elle suisse la famine qui voudront
mais venaient à dire cela ce bruit en
europe mais la vérité aussi c'est que
notre organisation de l'asile en europe
ne fonctionne pas ne fonctionne pas et
moi je ne peux pas me résoudre
effectivement à ce que encore en 2018 et
six personnes par jour qui soient mortes
noyées dans la méditerranée je veux
résoudre
oui à avoir un système européen où les
personnes qui demandent l'asile sont
renvoyés comme des balles de ping pong
d'un pays à l'autre et donc oui moi je
suis pour en europe la libre circulation
et qu'elle subit de son existence
jusqu'à contre la société n'est acquis
mais à deux connaissions sgs2 quoi je
suis en rien ce que l'on puisse défendre
les frontières de l'europe que l'on
puisse défendre les frontières de
l'europe
c'est exactement ce que le président de
la république a proposé quand il a
proposé de renforcer les moyens de
frontex et grâce à l'action de la france
nous aurons dix mille hommes pour
protéger les frontières de l'europe et
la deuxième condition l'adoré 2020 sion
c'est de faire en sorte que tous les
pays qui sont dans schengen jouent le
jeu de schengen jouent le jeu de la
libre circulation
c'est à dire soit qu'ils accueillent
vous demande d'asile soit qu'ils
contribuent financièrement si la jeanne
alors que laurent wauquiez ya trop
d'immigrés en france laurent wauquiez ou
pas c'est une question oui évidemment
mais bien sûr on a pourquoi parce qu'on
a dépassé nos capacités d'intégration et
quand on entend ce que dit monsieur
guérini on sait plus ni ce que dit
monsieur guérini ni même on finit par ne
plus savoir ce que dit monsieur castaner
mais il ya une réalité c'est qu'on a
plus de politique d'immigration
la réalité c'est que ça n'est plus le
gouvernement français qui choisit qui
rentre et qui reste en bas mais ça vous
l'avez vote on n'a jamais laissé autant
de titres de séjour dans notre pays que
depuis deux ans un record deux cent
cinquante mille personnes
quand quelqu'un est est condamné par la
justice et qu'on lui dit non vous n'avez
aucune raison légitime au regard de la
loi française de rester en france
dans 90% des cas maintenant il ne sera
jamais reconduits à la frontière et donc
il faut qu'ils aient des décisions qui
soient prises parce que je ne suis pas
du tout d'accord avec vous monsieur
guérini c'est quand vous laissez le
sentiment que ce serait une fatalité
ça n'est pas une fatalité si jamais il
ya des mesures qui peuvent être prises
la première mesure d'abord qui peut être
prises c'est d'adopter chaque année des
plafonds d'immigration qui permettrait
de diminuer massivement le nombre de
titres de séjour qu'on délivre la
deuxième chose est de retour je peux
vous rejoindre sur certains aspects
monsieur dupont-aignan
mais il faut être précis quand vous
dites oui d'accord
l'avenir de l'afrique il faut qu'on le
soutient d'accord et moi j'ai toujours
dit qu'il fallait faire en sorte que
l'avenir de la jeunesse africaine soit
en afrique s'il ya un point c'est qu'il
faut que ces aides soient conditionnées
bien sûr on ne peut pas continuer à
avoir des aides qui sont affectés une
évidence ricains vous l'avez pas
mentionné les tiges et les pensionnés à
royan en revoyant tout le fonctionnement
de l'aide au développement
c'est celle est mentionné pour sa
rêverie ces éléments monsieur dupont dit
non mais tant mieux si on peut si on
peut se retrouver sur ce point là tout à
fait ce que je voudrais au moins mais je
n'ai pas voté écolo qui tournait
attendez je vais vous irez jusqu'au bout
et c'est long permettra ensuite
d'échanger par exemple on a affecté
l'année dernière 300 millions d'euros au
mali le mali a accepté de reprendre même
pas 20 de ses ressortissants
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça sur et
donc il faut qu'on soit clair avec les
pays africains disant on va s'engager
plus fortement que ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui pour une vraie politique de
développement mais qu'ils soient
conditionnées en contrepartie de cette
aide il faut que les pays africains
s'engagent à reprendre ce
qui sont rentrés illégalement je
voudrais le continent voudrais juste
dire laurence ferrari laurence ferrari
je voudrais juste quand même répondre à
laurent wauquiez
non si vous me permettez quand même il
m'a aussi l'inde il martelé rapidement
justement vos kg me réjouis vous évoluez
mais de grâce
veillez à ce que vos députés au
parlement européen n'est pas voté toutes
les directives tous les traits toutes
les résolutions j'en ai un certain
nombre ne pas revenir dessus soutient
pacte de marrakech 18 avril 2018 en à
l'exception de madame morano
non sinon ils ont tous vouloir ma maman
me ah là là là vous me permettez mais un
gsm bien que vous preniez ses positions
le sait mais de grâce soyez cohérents
dans vos boîtes sont aignan vous avez un
léger moment qui a été un moment donné
tu te mets là oui parce que vous dites
qu'il faut avancer vers les 8 avril de
légers vous dire pourquoi et faire
marine genova monsieur dupont qui passe
par hasard mon nom socialiste je vais
vous dire pourquoi s'il avait voté le
débat et je me permets de vous répondre
parce que je n'aime pas votre assengone
à habas et de marcher sur la verite pas
diffusé de fausses informations aux
informations eric ça puisse prospérer de
sujets tous les votes à tanger tous les
votes des républicains
monsieur allemand monsieur le groupe
évoquait la volonté il faut une clarté
et laurent wauquiez dupont aignan dit
pas il ne fait pas la veille mais chez
dupont aignan savoir une clarté je
n'aime pas ce qu'ils cherchaient du p&g
a répondu très clairement il ya eu un
seul vote sur le pacte de marrakech ou
plaisante c'est le vote de décembre qui
lui dessine jour validé chacun vérifiera
l avantage c'est que maintenant
recommandera des tchèques news qui va
permettra très rap cialis ya quinze
jours avait voté est ce que je peux
juste articuler la piccola laisser
laurent wauquiez le plus prégnant et que
pour une fois ça me permettent de
découvrir toutes les photos informations
sur lesquels vous essayez de prospérer
au parlement européen puisque c'est l
interpellation de monsieur dupont-aignan
tout à fait il ya eu un vote définitif
sur le pacte de marrakech qui était en
décembre lors de ce vote de décembre la
totalité des élus républicains ont voté
contre
arrêtez de faire prospérer démentiel
reposer après la belgique les mâles sont
chacun pourra vérifier à 4 votre vision
à vous d'abord la question de
l'immigration je crois que c'est pareil
que d'autres tout à l'heure elle prend
beaucoup plus de place dans les débats
médiatico politique qu'elle n'a
d'intérêt pour les français d'ailleurs
certains ont récemment dit dans une
enquête d'opinion vous l'avez vu en
terme de classement
que la question de l'immigration est
loin derrière notamment la question du
pouvoir d'achat de l'emploi est la
première préoccupation des inventaires
d'abord une chose c'est que en la
matière aussi il faut désenfumer
regardons précisément entre 2015 et 2016
on a au porte de l'union européenne 1,2
million de demandeurs d'asile
ça fait 0,2 pour cent de la population
de l'union européenne de réfugiés pour
1000 habitants
regardons en france en 2010 700 me le
demande d'asile trente mille ont été
acceptés ça fait donc 0,06 pour cent de
la population française par conséquent
première chose il n'ya ni vague ni
submersion mais pendant que madame le
pen le fait croire vous avez des gens
qui n'ont jamais vu en migrant de leur
vie qui peut être n'en verront jamais
qui sont pris d'une peur panique réel de
cette question et pendant ce temps
madame le pen peut continuer à aller
dire qu'elle est contre la hausse du
ciri gwenaëlle peut parader
tranquillement avec ses alliés
autrichien qui font voter la semaine de
travail à 60 heures elle peut mettre sur
sa liste aux élections européennes des
gens qui sont pour la suppression de
l'sf etc
ensuite je ne veux pas évacuer le
problème 67 millions d'âmes le fait de
ne pas manquer la question madame le
bungee de vos électeurs ne voulait
vieillir l'aquaréna mme le pen vous
allez avoir beaucoup d'avant des
quartiers difficiles précisément alors
on leur a imposé madame le pen
cohabitation madame anastasie insupporte
revenons à la raison si vous le
supportez pas milliards 13 67 millions
de personnes aujourd'hui dans le monde
qui sont concernés par les migrations
forcées
je dis bien forcé madame le pen pas
qu'ils choisissent de quitter leur pays
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autre choix que de le
faire d'ailleurs albanaise 67 millions
de personnes exerçaient d'ailleurs gay
pays dépend de ce que vous dites d'assez
peu en général madame le pen 9 84% 80%
les mouvements migratoires se font entre
pays du sud et il ya des mouvements
migratoires d'ailleurs dans le débat
européen dont on ne vous parlera pas par
exemple le fait que 400 milles grecque
et était poussé à quitter leur pays pour
fuir les politiques d'austérité imposées
par bruxelles
le refus
alors maintenant regardons la question
moi je considère que c'est vos amis qui
sont plusieurs à se creuser tous les
fossés quand amy devrait vous pouvez
mettre tous les quotas que vous voulez
quand on voit que depuis les années 2000
à peu près trente mille personnes sont
portées disparues ou mortes en
traversant un fossé je pense pas qu'on
puisse faire plus grand que celui de la
méditerranée était devenue un véritable
cimetière je crois que vous pouvez faire
des gosses que vous voudrez vous ne
réglerez pas la question et je pense
compte tenu de la proportion que la
france peut prendre sa part une fois
qu'on a dit ça il faut dire que l'union
européenne est incapable d'organiser les
choses c'est complètement anarchique
avec notamment la règle de dublin permet
à 13h15 d'un déjeuner s'il vous plaît me
permettez c'est juste qu'on rencontre
une infographie will à nos
téléspectateurs auditeurs vous allez
réagir juste après il ya un rique un
problème notre sondage exclusif il
fallait de couper mon développe au
rythme mais vous pourrez je voulais
c'est le reprendre mais ça ils usent
ercis une précisément ce que je disais
allez-y pour gérer l'immigration aussi
la défense la lutte antiterroriste il
vaut mieux se placer sur un plan
européen c'est ce que disent les
français pour l'immigration est bien un
plan européen et bien à 102 reprises en
européenne est incapable d'organiser
cette question mais je vais vous dire
une chose parce que dans mon
raisonnement ce n'est pas suffisant il
ne serait pas complet si je ne disais
pas quelque chose c'est que le premier
des problèmes ce n'est pas que les gens
arrivent chez nous c'est qu'il soit
obligé de partir de chez eux et je vais
vous dire une chose aussi c'est que nous
avons des responsabilités dans le fait
qu'il soit obligé à partir de chez eux
j'en vois trois certains conflits des
guerres dans lesquelles nous avons mis
les mains notamment en étant arrimé à
l'otan dont il faut sortir les accords
commerciaux inégaux et les accords de
libre-échange d'abord qui font que comme
parfois quand madame le pen parlement
européen vote les accords de pêche avec
le libéria vous ruiner des capacités
localement et donc des gens finissent
par devoir partir et ensuite le
changement climatique et là on devrait
mettre tout le monde d'accord parce que
les experts du giec nous disent que
d'ici à 2050 si l'on mandic pas le
réchauffement climatique
ce ne sont plus 67 millions de personnes
mais 250 millions de personnes qui je le
répète ne vont pas madame le pen choisir
de partir mais ne pas avoir d'autre
choix que de le faire par conséquent il
faut traiter ces causes raisonnablement
et organiser les conditions de l'accueil
et de faire face mais à notre devoir le
plus certain qu'on nous voyons ces
images qui suivent un devoir d'humanité
mais il y a des gens et si qui depuis
longtemps
se sont emparés du sujet de
l'immigration pour en faire leur fonds
de commerce
est ce que vient de dire à l'instant à
rien qu'à tenace est l'exacte vérité il
n'ya pas de submersion et il ya quelques
minutes nous pallions d'identité
identité française identité européenne
aussi cette identité elle est aussi
celle de l'accueil
comment pourrions-nous aujourd'hui être
conforme à ce que nous sommes
si ces femmes ces hommes ces enfants
theresa méditerranée n'était pas
simplement accueilli la promesse de
monsieur maquereau au moment de
l'élection présidentielle c'était
précisément d'être un pays qui fait face
à sa sociabilité
j'avais même je me souviens rappelé
salué l'engagement des allemands et
d'angela merkel en 2015 depuis il est le
président qui a fermé la porte à 300
migrants avec l'aquarius voilà la
réalité l'autre une réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui c'est le même gouvernement
qui finance les garde-côtes libyens
écoutez bien ce que je vais vous dire
qu'ils financent les garde-côtes libyens
pour contenir l'immigration et tout le
monde sait l'onu en tête que c'est
garde-côtes sont eux
effectivement les complices des passeurs
que eu effectivement ce sont les
esclavagistes ce sont eux qui ensuite
dans les geôles en libye violent agresse
sexuellement font en sorte de mettre au
rancart animaux celles et ceux qui
effectivement n'ont pas réussi à passer
en méditerranée est donc cette question
at elle dit cette responsabilité là nous
l'avons toutes et tous et moi ce que
j'aimerais entendre dire ce soir de la
part de ce gouvernement c'est qu'il va
effectivement être conforme à ses
propres engagements qu'il ne va pas être
de ceux qui vont aller faire des
conférences de presse avec monsieur
salvini ça laisse à madame le pen elle
le fait très bien
elle adore ça mais vous êtes vous
j'aimerais pour vous quand même monsieur
guérini parce que vous avez eu d'autres
combats avant celui là j'aimerais que
vous reveniez à se caler votre identité
première que vous sachiez auger pour
retrouver au tt vous retrouvez votre
propre boussole parce que aujourd'hui on
ne sait plus très bien
cette force de dérivés sont innées c'est
sur le plan économique sur le plan
social et y compris sur le plan fort des
questions de migration q p un espace qui
n'aurait jamais dû être celui de
quelqu'un qui se prétend de progressis
qu est le pays qui a accueilli le plus
de personnes migrantes qui était sur
l'aquarius merlet la réponse est je vous
dis la réponse ne s'est pas dit que je
vous dis tout ça pourquoi user et chez
nous avons accueilli c'est pas des
grosses michel brand a été celui qui a
accès j'étais je vous répète que c'est
un concours c'est celui qui favorise
l'immigration ses extravagances je
réponds seulement cours
c'est pas un concours parler là de vies
humaines et de la famille qui sont morts
cette année mon vin ni laxisme famille
ce n'est pas un concours et votre la vie
arrêtez saxetbach démagogisme qui ne
vous honore pas vous allez donc vous
êtes vous plaît je vous laisse finir
votre embrouilles et puis j'aurais pu
n'y a pas d'embrouillé un des ces pagnes
soudan brouillon ses dirigeants même si
très sérieuse mais violet et je vous ai
répondu de façon très précise et parce
que le risque
vous nous avez fait oeuvre d'indignation
moi je vous ai répondu de façon précise
la france est le pays qui a accueilli le
plus de personnes que j'avais sera
faisait alors que l'accord est un côté
il y avait certains qui justement
pousser des cris d'orfraie en disant il
faut pas que le bateau puisse accoster
sur les côtes françaises de l'autre ceux
qui étaient dans l'indignation et
pendant ce temps là le gouvernement agit
c'est justement pour avoir une réponse
est assez répandu permanent le sort
discours il arrive à droite et la
réforme soit de coopération aujourd'hui
les étages avait germé lors des essais
et c'est très rare la clarté de nos
débats je vais essayer de terminer
terminé donc effectivement la seule
réponse possible c'est une réponse de
coopération entre les états européens
et moi je suis à l'assemblée le
rapporteur du budget de l'immigration et
j'ai vu que nous avons augmenté le
budget de 50% dans les deux premières
années ce quinquennat
justement pour cela les moyens les
rations mieux
mais au sur la coopération avait
commencé là c'est de finir parce que
sinon c'est un peu compliqué à répondre
dire c'est la réponse elle est au niveau
européen parce qu'on pourra mettre tout
l'argent qu'on veut en france si on
coopère pas mieux au niveau européen
mais sans accord la russie parce qu'on
vous fait pour les migrations est ce que
vous faites
on renforce pas les frontières au niveau
européen alors on va réveiller d'un sol
cela la question marine le pen on va
partir dans un instant à bruxelles pour
prendre des nouvelles de ce conseil
européen qui se tient vous voulez vous
exprimer un tout petit peu sur
l'immigration vous êtes sur youtube
avant que tu peux mais sur le temps de
parole vous êtes parmi ceux qui ont le
plus parlé je voulais je suis d'accord
mais enfin juger d'autres attendent pas
c'est quand même un sujet qui est
absolument majeur oui mais le
chronomètre et devant la même je tâche
et qui est de votre mouvement monsieur
gainey a dit la question des de
l'immigration se réglera aux élections
européennes alors moi je suis d'accord
avec lui et j'appelle les français avec
beaucoup de beaucoup de sérieux
attention ce que vous allez voter parce
que si vous croyez que l'union
européenne nous protégera d'une
immigration massive vous vous trompez
l'union peine et pro immigration
elle est pour l'arrivée des migrants
nous explique que les retraités les
retraites il faut les payer que tout ça
est pourquoi vous allez voter contre le
renforcement des frontières
stop moi je crois qu'il faut avoir des
frontières de l'emmener maîtrisé
monsieur salvini ses frontières
nationales donc chercher des exemples il
suffit d'aller regarder en italie en
italie la diviser par deux le nombre de
morts en méditerranée
voyez donc si vous voulez faire quelque
chose de si vous voulez faire
cette vision si vous voulez avoir une
vision humaine alors respectons sony le
solent de l'audience pour sommet de
baisse des débarquements et donc ça n'a
rien ajouté raymond 6 - 2 n'ont pas de
méditerranée menacé mais bien sûr que
oui parce que vous avez créé une
incitation à venir assure clandestine
mais vous croyez vraiment fière du
moment où vous dites aux gens tenter la
traversée risquer votre vie
si vous arrivez sur la plage alors vous
après rester et vous pourrez rester
pendant des années des années c'est
irrépressible et je vous le dis on vous
signale ailleurs déraisonnable vie avec
l'uimm s'est terminée la madeleine ce
que vous voulez
les formateurs c'est un binaire madame
le pen je pense que les critères celle
du droit d'asile doivent être
considérablement raffermi qu'il faut que
les demandes de droite de d'asile soit
faite exclusivement dans les consulats
et les ambassades françaises à
l'étranger et non pas sur le territoire
national car lorsqu on leur refuse le
droit d'asile et ils sont très nombreux
à se voir refuser le droit d'asile parce
qu'ils ne remplissent pas les conditions
qui ont poussé le territoire national
vous plaît alors moi j'ai bien entendre
monsieur quant à marine le pen de europa
cinémas marine le pen et ses pales
réchauffe allait mieux gérer les photos
on va avancer qu'il est connu que les
futurs leur est presque 23h marine le
pen à nice est pas pour ça et on va
passer respect les 1re année soit poussé
à la sortie soyez sérieux
[Musique]
telfrance donc dans quelle europe nous
questionnons ce soir votre adhésion au
projet européen
alors d'abord c'est l'actualité qui
ouvre cette séquence un conseil européen
extraordinaire qui se tient à bruxelles
sur le brésil en ce moment même quelle
attitude adopter face à londres faut-il
accepter un report nous partons pour
bruxelles retrouver isabelle ory
correspondante europe 1 là où tout se
décide pour l'union
bonsoir isabelle ou est-ce qu'on en est
à leur écoute et à cette heure ci le
sommet est toujours en cours
on attend toujours de savoir pour
combien de temps et sous quels sous
quelles conditions le bric site pourrait
être prolongé les 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement sont toujours en train de
dîner à huis clos aux quelques étages au
dessus de moi et ce qui est assez
frappant finalement quand on y pense
c'est que ces 27 hommes et femmes qui
représentent aussi un large éventail
politique ça va de la gauche avec le
grec alexis tsipras ce par exemple
hongrois viktor orban nous au chef du
gouvernement italien qui a allié de
matteo salvini et finalement ces gens
qui représentent un large éventail
politique comme vous inviter à eux en ce
moment ils sont en train d'essayer de
d'essayer de trouver ensemble un
compromis de construire ensemble une
solution
bon j'imagine que l'ambiance et est sans
doute différente de celle que vous avez
sur le plateau mais en même temps c'est
très typique de la politique au niveau
européen ici à beaucoup d'alliances
beaucoup de compromis c'est important de
construire des alliances et c'est comme
ça qu'on arrive à peser parce que tout
seul
en europe on n'y arrive pas à la france
par exemple tout seul ne pourra pas
changer les taux de tva dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure les députés
français tous seuls ne peuvent pas pesé
alors c'est un peu la question que j'ai
envie de poser à vos invités pourquoi
tout ça vous n'expliquez pas plus aux
français pourquoi vous leur faites
croire que l'europe c'est comme la
france en grand et pourquoi vous vous le
décrivez pas davantage cette réalité
politique européenne qui est si
différente de la réalité politique
française mais dont il faut tenir compte
si beaucoup isabelle ory en duplex de
bruxelles pour étayer votre question ce
sondage ifop pour ses new skies ne
montre qu'un français sur deux pense que
l'appartenance de la france à l'europe
est une bonne chose voilà c'est le
chiffre que nous voulions vous proposez
choix pour étayer notre débat mathieu
alors laurent wauquiez par rapport à ce
que
isabelle ory et puis pour relancer
l'europe parce que tout le monde a
ricané en plateau sur sur l'ambiance sur
ce plateau on est capables de travailler
ensemble 27 se sont aussi 27
sensibilités politiques différentes et
27 vision de l'europe différentes
pendant l'interpellation et je trouve
qu'elle est intéressante par rapport au
débat convient d'avoir et sur le rôle de
l'europe en essayant d'esquisser un
compromis ou peut-être plutôt un
dépassement des oppositions argos
monsieur guérini qui nous dit moi je ne
crois pas au fait qu'ils ont des formes
nationalement nos frontières à ma droite
madame le pen je lui reconnais une
constance de ce point de vue non c'est
pas l'europe qui doit défendre nos
frontières vous avez d'ailleurs voté
contre la totalité des moyens affectés
aux gardes-côtes européen et bien moi ce
que je pense et qu'au contraire il faut
conjuguer les deux il faut une double
procès récents quand même il faut une
double protection ses récents comme la
première chose vous permettait d'aller
cramer cie madame le pen je ne vous ai
pas interrompu intéressant parce que
vous n'avez jamais voté pour la
préservation des frontières nationales
monsieur laurent wauquiez je faisais pas
vous dire quand même le blâme le pen je
me permets de vous retourner la question
vous n'avez jamais voté pour une défense
européenne des frontières et ce faisant
aura vous faites une lourde erreur en ré
l'eau et j'ai essayé de vous l'expliquer
d'abord la première sauf s'il n'y a pas
une protection européenne de nos
frontières
s'il n'y a pas des vrais garde-côtes
européen vous ne vous pouvez pas
empêcher l'arrivée d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière sur notre
continent
c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
défense commune à la frontière de
l'espagne à la frontière de l'italie à
la frontière de la grèce et vous
commettez à mon avis une lourde erreur
de ne pas comprendre que c'est un
domaine typique
les français ne vous suivent pas
d'ailleurs là-dessus on a besoin d'une
coopération européenne et de défendre
ensemble nos frontières et par contre et
là je pense aussi monsieur guérini
qu'est une erreur de la proche
la france a le droit aussi de pouvoir
contrôler et protéger ses frontières par
rapport à des étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui rentreraient et c'est
pour ça que ce que nous nous proposons
c'est qu'il puisse y avoir une double
protection plus efficace
d'une part une protection et à quelques
pas avec des garde-côtes européen et
d'autre part une protection nationale
qui permettrait à la france
comme c'est d'ailleurs le cas
aujourd'hui à 26 me de pouvoir déployer
ses douaniers et sa police aux
frontières pour contrôler ce qui se
passe à la frontière espagnole et à la
frontière italienne et ce sujet est
intéressant parce qu'il montre d'une
part à mon avis l'erreur commise par
madame le pen qui est au fond de dire on
fait pas avec l'europe
mais l'erreur aussi par mathieu dernier
dans un excès de fédéralisme nous ce
qu'on essaye de faire
c'est au contraire de conjuguer à la
fois les domaines où l'europe peut-être
plus efficace sans pour autant que ça se
construisent sur le délabrement des
nations est-ce que laurence ferrari
puisque je suis interrogé je vais
répondre
en réalité ce que vous proposez de faire
c'est exactement nos possibilités
actuelles aux frontières françaises ou
en revanche pas du tout ce que nous
proposons de faire et du tout et que
c'est que l'on savait pas vraiment ce
que celle de l'immigration beaucoup plus
fort c'est pas vrai schengen mais vous
savez bien que ça n'est quand même pas
ce que vos alliés guérini dans vous
savez parlement de rangoun était faux et
non vous ne savez aujourd'hui rétablir
un contrôle aux frontières que dans un
seul cas c'est uniquement en cas de
menaces terroristes
vous nous l'avez d'ailleurs fait que
uniquement la frontière de vintimille
pas du tout à la frontière espagnole
fait le plein et elle sera beaucoup plus
efficiente parce que conditionné la
participation à schengen sas est
efficient dire que les pays ça ne passe
pas de dire si ça ne marche pas parce
que vous avez les aînés à l'élever au
parlement européen moi mais vous n'avez
plus aucun d'année nous arrêter nous
disons c'est que les suivra les jouent
pas le jeu justement de la coopération
en matière d'immigration ne pourront
plus participer à l'espace et quand vous
voudrez pour reposer les bourrasques et
la question d'isabelle ory aussi comment
vous l'imposé on arrive avec nos gros
bras à bruxelles
et nous français nous sommes en vie
quelles sont les règles savez quand on
est peut-être veut on peut il ya un
certain nombre de sujets sur lequel on
ne faisait que c'est absolument
impossible prenait la question du
travail des tâches est par exemple
impossible d'avancer
on est juste et ce que j'ai vu ce tout
simplement pas répond la france pour
dire alors que quand la france veut
quelque chose elle peut obtenir des
résultats
nous l'avons fait dans la campagne de
monsieur wauquiez pardon moitié un corps
de garde côtes qui à la demande des
états face à une pression migratoire
très importantes viennent filer un coup
de main à un état qui maîtrise ses
frontières j'y vois pas de mal pour les
avaient voté que je peux vous dire c'est
que les contrats dames le mazet vous
avez voté contre mais vous soyez parent
1er août ne chez vous ne venez pas sur
ce plateau
vous avez été conviés voté contre parce
que vous vous y allez vous poser au
moment où vous avez verte est
systématiquement contre la chevalier et
revenir renforcement des garde-fous tôt
dans la construction mais je veux tu
revois qui fait selon frontex neiges
jeunesse d'accorder des droits exclusifs
la réalité elle est là
est-ce qu'on pose est une agence
d'accueil ans à frontex à ça ça
aujourd'hui et c'est précisément comme
ça qu'ils font là ce sens émane des
bâtiments collectifs
enfin en même temps s'ils comptent en
millions d actions de pouvoir donner aux
pauvres mais je veux qu'ils aient envie
de pêcher de parler je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce qu'en réalité quand il
dit qu'il faut maîtriser ce que vous
dire 2 0 elle est une stupide voilà
c'est pourtant le même thème facile
quand même j'ai même pas exprimer une
idée doute déjà vous trouvez ça stupide
mais je trouve ça chez vous inquiet de
ne pas des vous avez voté avec vos
homebrews fonctionnent les républicains
au parlement européen la relocalisation
forcé des migrants dans les pays
par conséquent ne me dites pas
aujourd'hui que vous voulez défendre les
frontières nationales ce que vous vous
permettez à l'union européenne de faux à
la commission européenne d'obliger des
interpellé jacques cueillir des migrants
jusque dans tous les villages sont
adressées c'est ce que vivent nos
compatriotes aujourd'hui donc les nos
compatriotes qui dans leur village voit
arriver des migrants qui doivent dire
merci monsieur rocchi auquel j'ai été
interpellé je peux pas laisser ce que
vous ne savez pas si vous allez à vendre
mais illustre ce que disait isabelle ory
il ya une dizaine de minutes juste
essayé très simplement de répondre à
cette interrogation
à ce moment là quelle est la situation
la france était submergé l'allemagne
étaient submergés par un flux
d'immigration nous étions au coeur de
s'était encore ya quinze jours où est ce
que je peux est-ce que je vous avez
encore votre chose qu'est ce que j'ai
compris à droite extrême laisser passer
ou aux seconds les gens qui essaient de
vous apporter quelques éléments
le vote auquel vous faites référence
c'est un vote que j'assume totalement
qui a été destinée à dire une chose ça
n'est pas à la france et à l'allemagne
d'accueillir tous les migrants européens
et vous ne vous êtes pas honorer en ne
soutenant pas la démarche des députés
français pour faire en sorte que la
france ne soit pas la seule à accueillir
tous les flux de migrants et pour celles
encore une erreur que vous avez fait
vous êtes assez mal alors vous avez pu
vous exprimer et vous avez largement
s'exprime bien vite si on peut excuser
moi de dire que je trouve pathétique
cette course à l'échalote entre la
droite et l'extrême droite dans cette
affaire il a réservé un monsieur vous
qui vous êtes pas à vous excuser ne pas
d'extrême droite c'est pas grave on fit
trail c'est pas du tout mon temps j'ai
moi même sur ses pas l'intention de
s'excuser d'être de votre côté alors je
sais très bien où ça reste que peut y
arriver il ya aucune ambiguïté de ma
part la question qui était posée par
votre journaliste à bruxelles et
passionnante parce qu'en réalité le
problème qu'on a c'est que jusqu'à
maintenant les élections européennes
c'était en réalité les rapports de force
à l'intérieur de chaque pays et qui
ensuite se retrouvaient à bruxelles pour
faire des coalitions le plus souvent
c'était les sociaux-démocrates et les
démocrates-chrétiens sur la droite et la
gauche de gouvernement pour conduire la
destinée de l'europe et il ya un vide de
souveraineté on parle de souveraineté
depuis tout à l'heure
il ya un vide de souveraineté au niveau
européen c'est qu'en réalité le
parlement européen n'a pas le pouvoir
qu'ils devraient avoir
aujourd'hui ça ne paraît pas logique que
ce soient les chefs d'état qui ont les
discussions y compris par rapport aux
briques site
ça devrait être le parlement une
représentation du parlement qu'il le
fasse deuxième sujet et notre
journaliste a raison de le dire au
niveau du parlement
il ya des groupes politiques qui ne
recoupent pas toujours forcément ceux
auxquels on est habitué en france il ya
des groupes que je classerais plutôt d'
extrêmement hâte et d'ailleurs les amis
et madame le pen quand elle est élue
députée européenne sont avec le parti
you keep qui a mené la con non non non
non pour partir tromper la partie dans
les milieux n'était pas moi il ya une
partie du ppe qui on n'est pas loin de
supporter par monsieur vosges à gizeh où
vient aussi monsieur sorbonne avec une
diversité très importante entre madame
merkel oui mais prenons le temps de
parler de ces sujets là associant
discours revient sur le truc des
migrations et machin moi ça me dérange
pas mais enfin je trouve que c'est
dommage sûrement d'habitants la droite
du ppe au niveau européen il ya à la
fois monsieur norman qui est quasiment
d'extrême droite et madame merkel qui
est d'une autre inclination rapport aux
migrations
il ya le parti des sociaux démocrates où
là aussi il ya des différences il ya la
gauche unitaire européenne via la
différence et il ya le groupe des verts
l'enjeu des temps qui viennent c'est
qu'enfin qu'enfin le parlement européen
puisse conduire des politiques et avoir
la responsabilité devant les citoyennes
et citoyens européens de mener des
politiques et des polders ans ferrat et
je commence qu'aujourd'hui dans les
temps qui viennent si on veut donner et
vous me posez la question comment on
change l'europe si on veut changer
l'europe il faut enfin que cette europe
soit démocratique des délégations de
pouvoir et donc au parlement européen on
parle aujourd'hui ce qui est terrible
c'est le vide de souveraineté manière
que ceux qui décident au niveau européen
ce ne sont pas ceux qu'on ai dit qu'à
reconduire des quolibets et européennes
ce sont les chefs d'état qui n'ont pas
été élus pour ça et ça c'est une
catastrophe démocratique
ça ne pourra pas durer comme ça parce
que si on continue dans cette direction
on vivra encore ce qui s'est passé en
grande bretagne avec le break site ce
qui est une calamité delà du poignant
d'abord moi je voudrais regarder les
faits depuis vingt ans la gauche et la
droite de gouvernement ont signé tous
les traités d'ailleurs moi j'ai quitté
l'ump à l'époque quand il ya eu le
traité de lisbonne qui reprenait les
dispositions de la constitution
européenne qui avait été rejeté par le
peuple français cette trahison du
référendum nous a amenés à créer debout
la france parce qu'en vérité on
s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui cette europe
ne marche pas cette europe où on a
transféré des pouvoirs extravagants
à trois organismes dont les membres ne
sont pas élus la commission de bruxelles
la banque centrale la cour de justice et
nos gouvernements successifs vous et
lisez les présidents de la république
les uns après les autres ils sont
prisonniers de règles et ils ne peuvent
pas s'en extraire si cette europe avait
au moins créer des grands projets comme
airbus ariane s'était pas l'union
européenne c'est pts et des coopérations
au moins on pourrait dire bon mais en a
abandonné des pouvoirs mais ils ont fait
quelque chose
ils ont échoué sur tous les domaines
bureaucratie d'hommes pini social
incapacité à créer de grands projets
pour affronter la chine et les états
unis alors ya deux solutions maintenant
il y en a que deux soit on part dans une
optique fédéral et au moins en marche et
cohérent les verts aussi ils veulent une
europe fédérale ça veut dire cap une
nation il ya plus de france les français
ne voteront plus pour leur liberté ils
confient leur destin dans une europe
fédérale c'est un choix cohérent c'est
pas le mien mais il est cohérent
soit on revient à la seule europe qui
peut marcher c'est l'europe des nations
ce que j'appelle l'europe des nations
libres et des projets concrets on
renvoie on renvoie au peuple la maîtrise
de leurs frontières nationales de leurs
lois primauté du système juridique
c'est-à-dire des lois françaises bien
évidemment aux leurs budgets on arrête
de financer les délocalisations les
travailleurs détachés des autres pays
c'est comme un scandale
chaque nation reprend sa respiration
démocratique et là vous verrez que le
suffrage servir à quelque chose d'élire
un président de la république mais ça
n'interdit pas et c'est le point
fondamental de l'europe gaullienne du
début de l'europe
ça n'interdit pas des coopérations sur
des projets à la carte
pourquoi on est incapable de développer
la souveraineté numérique
l'intelligence artificielle eu un
programme pour la méditerranée pour
l'afrique
pourquoi on est incapable de lutter
contre le cancer ou alzheimer pas de
projets de coopération un coup dur mais
ça se fera pas à 28
mais comment d'ailleurs laurent wauquiez
combien de temps bien nicolas dupont
aignan qui élargissait le relais du
banian est maintenant facile c'est tout
blanc de croire qu'on bien que ça ceux
qui veulent sérieusement non je finis
retard
j'avais beaucoup de retard c'est une
europe à projets à géométrie variable
ont fait à quatre pays un projet sur la
lutte contre le cancer parce qu'on a des
industries pharmaceutiques comme en
affaires bus
et puis on laisse les nations vivront
leur envoi l'ensemble des compétences on
supprime la commission c'est notre
projet debout la france c'est à dire un
projet et vous retard sur la démocratie
et vous avez pu l'annoncer
adrien 4 nages votre vision de l'europe
à vous on aborde ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que l'idéal de coopération entre
les peuples qui était l'idéal européen à
sa fondation a été dévoyé aujourd'hui
l'union européenne c'est juste un marché
et d'ailleurs on parlait à l'instant du
brds excite le break site est un des
symptômes de la dislocation en cours de
l'union européenne il ya encore quelques
temps se poser la question savoir
qu'elle allait être le prochain pays qui
allait rejoindre l'union qu'elle allait
être le prochain traité que nous allions
signer aujourd'hui on se pose la
question est ce que c'est que c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui est à l'ordre du jour
quel les prochains pays qui va quitter
ainsi européenne voilà ce cadre du jour
aujourd'hui
l'union européenne telle qu'elle
fonctionne et dans le cadre de ces
traités particulier n'est pas la
solution puisqu'elle est une partie du
problème tout à fait on à monsieur john
coeur qui nous dit il n'y a pas de choix
démocratique possible contre les traités
et bien manon aubry la candidate que je
défends est l'anti john coeur elle dit
il n'y a pas de traité possible contre
la démocratie
voilà ce qu'il faut rappeler nous sommes
les héritiers du nom de 2005 des
français au traité européen lequel a été
foulée au pied par les amis de monsieur
wauquiez n'est que nicolas sarkozy avec
le traité de lisbonne et je crois que
c'est une cicatrice qui reste
aujourd'hui pleinement ouvertes ensuite
beaucoup de candidats et notamment
madame l'oiseau nous vendent sans cesse
dans un régime très incantatoire assez
peu concret l'europe qui protège et
quand les français regardent de très
près que voit-il est ce que l'europe
protège la démocratie telle qu'elle
fonctionne aujourd'hui quand les grecs
font un choix souverain et que
immédiatement la banque centrale
européenne et les autres viennent les
saisir à la gorge pour leur faire
appliquer la seule pause la seule
politique est possible d'appliquer dans
l'union européenne ferait l'ordo
libéralisme est ce que l'europe protège
l'environnement
quand elle nous oblige à continuer le
libre échange le ceta et d'ailleurs ça
nous fait un point de discussion avec
monsieur corman puisque moi je crois
précisément que dans le cadre des
traités actuels
nous ne pouvons pas mener je le regrette
de politique écologique ambitieuse
le geiq nous dit faut investir
massivement les 3% de déficit nous en
empêche je prends un autre exemple si on
veut interdire le glyphosate
il faut aussi faire en sorte que les
produits glyphosate et n'arrive pas sur
notre territoire les traiter en vertu de
la libre concurrence nous en empêche
est ce que l'europe protège les droits
sociaux quand on poursuit la directive
du travail détachées
en madame le pen était absente au moment
du vote en 2014 bref on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui telle qu'elle fonctionne
ça ne marche pas alors entre écologie et
traités il faut choisir entre sociale et
écologique centre social et il faut
choisir est je crois qu'entre l'europe
et ses traités il faut choisir
je termine en posant une question à
monsieur guérini puisque tout de même la
dame loiseau après qu'est votre
candidate 1 j'ai bien compris ce soir
que vous n'étiez pas garant de toutes
les positions du gouvernement mais
supporter quand même que les positions
de votre candidate on vous les attributs
mais je le mouvement chez madame
supporter très bien à savoir si vous
allez avoir une réponse année les 6 à me
donner et j'en suis réjoui alors
monsieur guérini j'ai lu l'intervention
récente de madame l'oiseau qui peut être
maintenant va commencé à esquisser un
programme et elle nous dit je veux un
smic européen
c'est intéressant ça c'est d'ailleurs là
le elle le chiffre elle dit le smic
européen pourrait être un revenu décent
aux seuils de pauvreté où elles ont des
revenus décents de smic européen à 886
euros
c'est à dire que l'europe des solutions
de madame l'oiseau c'est amputer le smic
français et de là soit 117 euros
c'est sa part sans l'aide des solutions
monsieur guérini alors je sais garder
votre réponse à bord une réponse précise
sur la question elle lorsque l'humain
effectivement effectivement % que
l'europe doit se réinvestir sur les
sujets prioritaires et notamment la
lutte contre le dumping social
comment accepter les utiliser cet euro
même les arts et le diadème 6000 euros
au luxembourg et donc nous la preuve que
nous portons c'est effectivement d'avoir
un bouclier social pour les européens
d'avancé derrière nous les filles on
s'éteint mais un sionisme est un soin de
garder au niveau de vie des pays
européens et donc la proposition peut
formuler du tout c'est de faire en sorte
que le smic soit dans chaque pays à plus
de 50% du salaire bien les français vous
entendu
déjà mais convergents un salaire à
minorer six mêmes phrases mais
n'était-ce pas besoin de convergence
pour justement que lé smic dans les pays
européens puissent monter et ne
sauraient en aucun cas cette année vous
vous jetez à nous dire ce qu'ils
résident et écoutez le ecoutez-le
vraiment ça direct ce soir ça mérite
d'être écouté 50% du salaire médian
c'est la façon dont on calcule le seuil
de pauvreté
voilà que la république en marche dont
il ce soir olivier le wolf hisser le
niveau du smic européen ou au niveau du
seuil de pauvreté
et voilà ce qu'ils nous disent c'est
qu'il faut les écarter s'est inquiétée
pas même les bulgares
c'est sûr si on faisait tout à l'heure
mais non c'est un fait c'est ce qu'a dit
la candidate
malheureusement oui mais ce qu'a refusé
moisi nous luttons et s2 dalle monsieur
social et donc la proposition et comment
voulez vous lutter contre le dumping
c'est une fiction de smic européen qui
va être au niveau du seuil de pauvreté
etc européen m'en voulez vous monsieur
fiscales n'ont rien de ces grands noms
mais peuvent comprendre
gérald allard olivier faur puis
stanislas guerre il que tout le monde
peut comprendre c'est que si on veut
lutter contre le dumping
c'est à dire le fait que y ait des pays
qu'ils soient effectivement dans le
moins disant il faut non seulement avoir
un smic dans tous les états européens
qui ne peut pas être fixé comme le fixe
madame l'oiseau au niveau du seuil de
pauvreté fixé comment est il faut aussi
il faut le fixé par exemple à 70% du
salaire médian
c'est ce qui pourrait avoir mais si bien
sûr c'est un lien avec chaque niveau de
vie dans chaque pays sont jouées en
sorte que ça permette je vais avoir un
niveau ensuite il faut mais que nous
verrons demain jeudi si le d'aller
jusqu'aux monsieur faure n'est pas je
ferais si je te fit renaître et il faut
ensuite et un agenda de convergence et
parce que si vous ne faites pas
converger les différents smic
évidemment il ça fait bien il n'y aura
pas d'urgence
le même sujet a tenté avant chaque
élection les six nations quels sont vos
comptes propositions concrètes d'urgence
qui manie la forêt en matière de
pollution n'était pas avec eux leurs
tâches de guillemette à l'ats isabelle
ory on en reparle à l'environnement n'a
pas de frontières c'est pour cela qu'on
décembre 2015
195 pays ont conclu l'accord de paris
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique
son objectif principal contenir le
réchauffement de la planète en dessous
de 2 degrés par rapport aux niveaux pré
industriels
pourtant en 2018 les émissions de
dioxyde de carbone ont franchi un niveau
historique 37,1 milliards de tonnes
produites en hausse de 2 7% en un an
après la chine et les états unis l'union
européenne fait partie des trois plus
gros pollueurs au sein de l'europe la
moyenne de co2 émis par habitant s'élève
à près de 9 tonnes la france est un peu
mieux chaque habitant n'aimait que sept
tonnes par an c'est deux de moins que
quinze ans plus tôt est beaucoup moins
qu'un allemand qui lui est à mons tonnes
d'ici 2050 un objectif neutralité
carbone a été fixée par le parlement
européen
ce qui suppose d'absorber le carbone
soit naturellement soit par des procédés
industriels avec son parc nucléaire
la france y est favorable contrairement
à l'allemagne ou au pays de l'est comme
la pologne ou la hongrie plus dépendants
du charbon et du gaz
la norvège qui ne fait pas partie de
l'union européenne a prévu elle de
l'atteindre dès 2030 si la france est
plutôt bon élève pour le climat elle est
en revanche poursuivi devant la justice
européenne pour sa mauvaise qualité de
l'air comme neuf autres états en effet
la pollution de l'air est responsable de
nombreux décès prématurés 659 mille
morts dans l'union européenne dont
soixante sept mille en france selon les
chiffres de l' oms pour l'année 2015
david cormand pour europe ecologie les
verts qu'est ce que vous proposez de
créer une barrière écologiques alliant
écologie que j'en sais rien mais un
protectionnisme vert oui c'est important
on a beaucoup hésité avant d'utiliser ce
terme de protectionnisme parce qu'il est
habituellement attribués à des personnes
qui souhaitent uniquement protéger les
intérêts
de leur nation cg normalité j'ai les
ouvriers protectionnisme dont ses
gérants des fonds non c'est de défendre
l'intérêt global de l'humanité en
réalité aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
modèle économique est un véritable
pousse au crime s'est recueilli à un
bonus pour ceux qui détruisent quand on
détruit l'environnement ça rapporte de
l'argent quand on exploite les personnes
ça rapporte de l'argent quand on
délocalise ça rapporte de l'argent et
donc l'idée de ce protectionnisme
d'ailleurs c'est à dire que les règles
écologiques que nous avons en europe
doivent s'appliquer à celles et ceux qui
veulent bénéficier du marché européen
nous avons une chance nous sommes le
poste est une chance d'ailleurs tout cas
nous sommes le premier marché du monde
et donc quand on est le premier marché
du monde nous avons la possibilité
d'induire des pratiques économiques à
nos partenaires je suis d'accord avec
monsieur 4,9 sur la malédiction des
traités de libre échange et c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi les écologistes
depuis toujours monsieur 4 mars les ont
combattues et monsieur jadot a été l'un
des premiers au combat lorsqu'il eut ces
histoires de settat taffetas qu'ils
allaient apparaître mais les très
nombreux sujets oui je viens aussi tu
viens mais parfois il ya la confusion
dans les propos entre traité de
libre-échange et traités européens
nous ce que nous pensons c'est que dans
les traités actuels
il y a possibilité d'agir vous avez
parlé à très juste titre de monsieur
juncker et de la monoactivité économie
de musique 100 boer qui est organisé
l'évasion fiscale nous ce que nous
proposons c'est non pas de sortir les
pays qui ont des difficultés en
développement économique mais plutôt de
nous adresser aux paradis fiscaux au
coeur même de l'europe il y en a
j'ai parlé du luxembourg et à l'irlande
les pays bas et à chypre
et aujourd'hui avec les traités actuels
c'est l'article 7 on peut absolument
privées de vote
ces pays au niveau du conseil s'il ne
respecte pas un certain nombre de règles
communes dont la question de la
fiscalité
j'en viens sur la question de fond que
la question clé est de ce fait il n'y a
pas d'autre j'ai un très important
il n'y a pas d'autres sujets que la
question climatique aujourd'hui nous
n'arriverons pas à construire un avenir
pour les peuples européens sans
s'attaquer à la question climatique et
donc la question qu'il faut
m je reviens sur les traiter c'est que
nous proposons à traiter
environnementales se traitait
environnementale
doit diriger tous les autres et à
l'intérieur de ce traité il ya la
question de lutter en faveur du climat
il ya la question de mettre des normes
économiques qui arrête de détruire la
nature je pense notamment aux échos side
et à l'effondrement de la biodiversité
que nous sommes en train de connaître ça
on ne peut le faire que si l'europe et
prescriptrice de bonne attitude en
matière environnementale et c'est
l'enjeu du temps qui viennent c'est
parmi toutes les propositions que nous
faisons une ruelle du poignant moi je
dis bravo pour un protectionnisme
environnemental mais ce que je trouve
fascinant chez les verts c'est que quand
nos ouvriers bien ça sinon à plein de
points de vue monsieur du fascinant
quand les ouvriers perdent leur boulot
les agriculteurs un agriculteur se
suicident tous les deux jours on ne
demande pas de protectionnisme
quand c'est la classe sûr que ce rapport
c'est ce que je veux dire à mes joueurs
dans un harry c'est pas con que je peux
exprimer ma pensée les et nicolas ce que
je veux lui bien penser que le fond
david cormand parce que ce qu'il a dit
n'est pas ce que vous dites
et bien moi je vous dis ce que je pense
je trouve fascinant mais répondait au
moins que je connais tu te laisser moi
répondre comme je l'entends ce que je
trouve fascinant c'est que la qualité de
l'air vous permet de dire il faut un
protectionniste ce que je revendique
depuis des années d'amour nous ouvriers
nos agriculteurs ce qui veut dire d'une
manière plus générale que si on veut
vraiment protéger la planète
à ce moment là il faut localiser
relocaliser des millions d'emplois en
europe pour relocaliser des millions
d'emplois il faut stopper ce libre
échange déloyal
elle a complètement dingue qui ont été
mis en place je vous ferai le rappelle
que le fameux c'est à l'accord avec le
canada
emmanuel macron avait promis pendant la
présidentielle n'ont pas de re négocier
mais de revoir en confiant une
commission l'examen de ce c'est à la
commission
la fameuse commission émis un rapport
assez sévère et bien au parlement
français nous n'avons toujours pas
l'assemblée nationale votée sur le ceta
et on nous dit que ça a été déléguée que
ça sera peut-être après les européennes
deuxième point le maire révision et le
mercosur
c'est à dire le traité de libre échange
avec l'amérique latine qui va être un
désastre pour nos agriculteurs
alors là on n'en parle plus mais vous
verrez qu'il va ressortir après les
européennes
cela veut dire très clairement qu'il
faut maintenant changer de logique mais
changer de logique
comme on a perdu le droit de veto sur
une partie des négociations de
libre-échange
ça veut dire que la france avec le
traité de lisbonne et c'est pourquoi je
vais contester ce traité a perdu la
capacité de bloquer et voilà pourquoi
sol eu un moment une france forte qui
dise stop je joue plus je n'accepte plus
est traitée libre échange parce que
sinon avant chaque élection européenne
on aura le même cinéma encore chaque
élection européenne
on entend europe sociale protection de
l'environnement et puis ensuite tout ce
beau monde va là bas
et comme on applique toujours les
menacer monsieur nicolas bien ça passe
laurendeau classé propres avec ce traité
les renégocier sous les traiter la salle
répond c'est le protectionnisme
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
est fou de laisser rentrer en europe des
produits qui sont produits dans des
conditions qui ne respectent aucune des
normes environnementales qu'on
s'applique à nauman un exemple très
concret vous pêcher du poisson en
norvège il est ensuite envoyé en chine
où il est conditionné pour être vendue
en france surgelés c'est une absurdité
au moment où on parle de développement
durable
moi je pense qu'il faut des choses qui
soient très simple et très nette
nous ce qu'on propose avec notre
candidat françois xavier belani c'est
une barrière écologique mais très simple
tout produit qui a été fabriqué dans des
pays qui ne s'applique pas les normes
environnementales que nous nous
appliquons doit acquitter une taxe à
l'entrée et cette taxe servira à quoi
elle servira à faire de l'écologie par
l'incitation et par l'aide au lieu de le
faire par les impôts comme ça a été fait
depuis deux ans en france
david cormand laurent wauquiez nicolas
dupont aignan adrien 4 nages je crois
aussi on a un point de convergence sur
cette question du protectionnisme
bon d'abord ce qu'il faut remarquer
c'est que effectivement à l'approché des
élections européennes tout le monde est
écologiste alors il ya des nuits henri
texier sécu c'est plutôt bien d'ailleurs
qu'est ses nuances ça me permet de te
débattre et de voir un peu quelles sont
nos points d'accord une pente
divergences d'abord on a le parti de
monsieur corman qui depuis longtemps et
nous lui devons a mis ce sujet au centre
il en a fait son nom puis on a le parti
de monsieur qu'est guérini qui
aujourd'hui présente madame l'oiseau qui
fait de l'asile politique en matière
d'écologie puisqu'on à monsieur qu'enfin
quai numéro deux de la liste dont on ne
peut pas douter qu'il soit un écologiste
au net
et puis on a un numéro 4 une personne
qui défendent l agriculture
productiviste qui d'ailleurs était très
opposé au ctac emmanuel macron appliquée
et il faut rappeler tout de même que ce
c'est à vient écraser les accords de la
cap 21
ces contrats dilatoire nous en sommes
rendus à cette étape où aujourd'hui la
pollution dans notre pays la pollution
de l'air tue 67000 ma personne
prématurément chaque année de la même
manière ce que l'on mange empoisonne et
la pérennité de la vie humaine sur terre
est menacée c'était quand même à ce
niveau là qu'il faut lisser le débat sur
la question écologique et je le disais
tout à l'heure les scientifiques nous
disent on a 12 ans provient de modèle
économique qui polluent c'est une vraie
question
parce que moi je ne crois pas à
l'écologie punitive ou comme le disait
hier edouard philippe dans l'hémicycle à
l'assemblée à l'écologie de la
responsabilité individuelle
ça ça ne marche pas d'autant plus quand
on sait que à peu près 25
multinationales ont été à l'origine de
71 % des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par conséquent je crois que nous
ne pouvons pas attendre l'écologie des
petits pas et compte tenu de l'urgence
temporel ne pouvons pas attendre non
plus que les petits ruisseaux phase de
grande rivière donc faut prendre de
grandes décisions politiques qui nous
mettent toutes et tous au pied du mur de
faire quelque chose d'important d'amples
raison pour laquelle je propose la règle
verte
elle pourrait être également une
directive européenne et faire que toutes
les politiques du coup nécessite que
l'on fasse la planification et je leur
dis et je le regrette un débat entre
nous je crois que dans ce cadre là on ne
peut pas faire d' écologie ambitieuse
dans le cadre des traités ceux qui vous
disent que l'on peut faire une écologie
à la hauteur du moment dans le cadre des
traités soit sont malheureusement naïf
soit vous mentent sciemment ce qui
serait plus de motifs article si vous
êtes d'accord pour sortir des traités
comme le ceta notamment ce qui ouvre la
porte aux pesticides et aux ogm
moi je suis pour qu'on soumette tous les
traités de libre-échange tout et
commerciaux aux accords de la cap 21
on ne peut pas avoir été à la fois le
pays qui a permis les accords de la coop
21 et ne pas ensuite exigé qu'il soit
appliqué par l'union européenne premier
point deuxième point je suis
effectivement aussi pour un
protectionnisme vert et pas seulement
vers social aussi à roses et verts si
vous voulez parce que je veux qu'on
puisse ne pas être les idiots utiles de
la mondialisation que l'europe soit le
seul endroit on applique des règles sur
la concurrence que personne n'applique
dans le monde
troisième point je suis ailleurs la
tribune pierre larrouturou qui est
l'auteur avec jean jouzel le grand
climatologues du giec qui a été l'auteur
d'un pacte finances climat
il est sur la liste de raphaël
glucksmann envie d'europe écologique et
sociale et qui porte bien son nom est
donc ce quelques proposons nous vous
proposons de reprendre à notre compte ce
pacte finances climat quand il a fallu
au moment de la réunification allemande
faire en six mois
la banque européenne de reconstruction
et de développement ça a été fait
aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'on a 10 ans
pour sauver la planète
eh bien il faut le faire aussi que
proposons-nous une banque qui soit une
banque climat qui soit une banque qui
utilisent la création monétaire pour
faire des prêts non l inverse
c'est emmanuel macron qui vient de se
nicher dans une proposition qui était né
avant lui et que nous portons que vous
appliquez une évidemment mais ça dépend
ce qui met dedans mais j'ai aussi les
points de convergence sur les chapeau
c'est bien on a tous le même chapeau
enfin après c'est qu'est ce qu'on met
dessous et moi ce que je vous dis c'est
qu'il faut que cette banque climat elles
puissent utiliser la création monétaire
aujourd'hui pour faire en sorte qu'on
puisse à des prêts à taux zéro la bce en
génie 85 milliards par mois de l'adria
qu à rien je voulais finir donc qui
permettent d'injecter chaque année des
prêts à taux zéro dans chaque état et
permettre de financer la transition
énergétique d'année points je souhaite
aussi il nous reste quelques minutes
après une question des traités et que
nous puissions aussi faire en sorte
désormais que tous les investissements
étatiques plusieurs suggestions
nationaux qui sont faits adresse dans la
transition énergétique ne soit pas
corrélées dépendant des trois sens de
maastricht qu'on puisse avoir un effort
conséquent qui puisse permettre à tous
les états de faire ce qu'ils doivent
faire
parce que demain il sera trop tard
stanislas guérini sur ces questions
d'environnement de climat de la qualité
de ce que nous mangeons aussi ce matin
encore vous y avez fait référence
monsieur 4 nantes jérémy decerle numéro
4 la liste de la république en marche
parler de cinq ans pour la sortie du
glyphosate on sort quand au juste
non si la france n'avait pas agi en
l'occurrence sur le glyphosate et jour
merci de me poser la question et bien
l'union européenne s'apprêtait à
prolonger l'autorisation du glyphosate
pour 15 ans puis dix ans et grâce à
l'action de la france ce rapt a été
prolongée que
pour cinq ans et nous nous avons pris
une position en france plus volontariste
de dire que justement nous voulons
sortir en trois ans oui mais oui tout à
fait vous avez refusé mais d'accueil
matin jérémy les salles parle quand
c'est juste mais un tweet et j'adore les
islais justement cela que nous portons
c'est à dire au delà des discours nous
portons ou vision qui réconcilie
l'agriculture en parle écologie et c'est
tout le sens d'avoir des personnalités
déjà mais reçoit une autre liste qui
défendent des positions parole commune
sur l'écologie mais ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que leur fort heureusement au
moment où en france il ya un français
toutes les dix minutes qui meurent à
cause de la pollution heureusement qu'on
essaie de trouver des points de
convergence et je suis très heureux que
les différentes personnes autour la
table et repris la proposition qu
emmanuel macron avait formulé dans le
discours la sorbonne de mettre en place
une taxe carbone aux frontières de
l'europe qu'au delà des discours le
président de la république je dise et
actes justement que nous ne signe pas
d'accord commercial avec les pays qui
sont sortis de l'accord de paris négocié
il faut aller au delà notamment comme on
peut oublier le sport est investie
risque élevé chez nous en europe à la
voix vais pas dire des choses pareilles
se laisse aspirer ni le président
français et on ne niera convient
d'accepter l'idée de négocier un traité
l'affairé ensablement snap avec les
états unis justement qui sont en très
relevée fort lisez les journaux à la
france et les journaux et les agressions
les délais même sembla de la france est
il ya des jeux qui dérape encore hier
est un journal j'ai encore accueillir
vais de temps en temps qui indique que
ce que vous dites est faux l'avenant ce
nom à temps a donné demande a pourri la
beauté sa gang au maire est plus exposé
le canada est en l'occurrence le sien
durant cinq d'accord avec un pays taxent
ayant bercé par monsieur guérini qu'est
ce que vous en pensez bien je devrais me
réjouir en réalité de cette victoire
idéologique parce que pendant très
longtemps on s'est battu pour le
protectionnisme un peu tout seul et on
était confronté à tous ceux qui nous
expliquait que pas du tout il fallait
absolument accompagner les accords de
libre échange et à part faut être
honnête les verts et et le mouvement de
monsieur mélenchon tous les autres nous
ont imposés les accords de libre-échange
me connaît bien sûr goethe intègre pas
le change en toute circonstance ils ont
défendu cette europe ultralibérale avec
les ravages écologiques qui en sont
évidemment les conséquences parce que
les accords de libre échange c'est la
mise en concurrence de nos productions
de nos agriculteurs avec des productions
dont on sait pertinemment que elle ne
respecte pas l'environnement qu'elles
n'ont aucune norme sanitaire aucune
norme sociale d'ailleurs et honnêtement
vous entendre aujourd'hui dire il faut
arrêter ça joue un bonheur félicité bon
en revanche qu'est ce que vous proposez
la menace a justement ça fait des années
un pardon mais là pour le coup j'ai une
toute petite antériorité sur le fait qu'
il m'apparaît que d'autres ne peut pas
on ne peut pas accepter l'importation en
france de produits qui sont interdits de
production enfants ça me paraît simple
ça mais par exemple il ya un insecticide
pour les cerises
on a interdit les scepticismes aux
producteurs de cerises
bon jusque là tout va très bien sauf que
le lendemain et bien ils ont retrouvé
les cerises qui ont été cultivés avec le
même insecticides
à côté des leurs sur le marché du
village du quoi évidemment moins cher
bon ben ok ça parce que je dis est ce
que vous assumez le fait qu'on autorise
a distribué à l'international des
produits qui sont interdits en france
mais en réalité la question c'était est
ce qu on arrête tout de suite avec cette
filière là on délocalise 2500 emplois
parce que c'est ça dont il s'agit et ont
continué la production de ces produits
là justement pour les retrouver
n'importe quoi et bien non mais nous
avons assumé mais c'est juste interdit
les importations c'est toujours une
position différente qui était de dire
que nous saisirons dégagements alors
c'est finir là c'est vous qu'on
s'interdit continue à l'aimer juste un
mot juste un an au moins je suis
certains mots parce que papa m'a même le
pen on a la sienne rapidement monsieur
fiore puis juste d'un no comment madame
le pen peut nous expliquer que au fond
elle avait tout lieu donc tout le monde
mais sur ces sujets il y avait le nom
app est venu vers moi
il y avait même pas ce que vous allez
rester en europe
comment vous pouvez vous le maintenant
de nous expliquer que vous aviez prévu y
compris des partenaires devraient en
sortir
bien que pour vouloir une solution
désormais ses nouveaux noms m'excuse
mais nicolas mais il me pose une
question récollets la vie la correction
il ya deux ans le rendement non parce
que les bibelots livres cadeaux en
europe mais chez vélo parce que les moon
ont vécu dans une solution alors tenez
le rhdp dans ses solutions et me plaît
c'est de pauvres et les loue des minutes
avant la contagion autre avis et bien
sont de plus en plus puissants au point
que l'euro tout pourrait bien vous avez
construite solution
chez dupont aignan la masse critique
pour que l'europe ne soit jetée dit
plusieurs fois ce soit en plus crue du
ruisseau dans le bon sens du terme
d'abord on a besoin de l'europe on a
besoin de cette masse critique d'avoir
tous ces citoyens tous ses états qui
sont réunis dans une même direction ça
que lesdits le traité environnementales
que nous souhaitons faire ce que dans
les traités actuels
il ya moyen d'agir mais il faut les
changer si on veut avoir une nouvelle
ambition en matière climatique et de
préservation de la biodiversité et donc
ce nouveau traité environnantes et il
doit se faire via la question de
l'investissement on a parlé de la
question de la banque du climat
c'est selon ce que les uns ou les autres
10 100 millions 100 milliards pardon
d'euros par an pendant cinq ans a fait
500 milliards mais je voudrais parler un
petit peu d'agriculture très rapidement
on n'en a pas parlé beaucoup c'est aussi
tout le budget actuel de l'europe
là c'est pas de l'argent de la planche à
billets qu'on fait fonctionner c'est le
budget de l'europe
et là aussi il faut rien aurait remonté
de dépenses aujourd'hui il a encore la
pac est un pousse au crime
c'est un pousse au crime par rapport au
modèle agricole qui détruit
l'environnement et surtout qui détruit
les paysannes et les paysans en france
depuis l'après guerre
c'est le plus gros choc de perte
d'emploi qu'on a eu dans notre pays ces
cinq millions d'emplois qui ont disparu
et aujourd'hui les seuls alliés des
agricultrices et des agriculteurs pour
construire demain l'agriculture du 21e
siècle pardon de le dire mais ce sont
les écologistes n'ont aujourd'hui ils
sont pris en tenaille les protections
qui au total il vous plaît par l'agro
industrie par l'agroalimentaire les
géants de l'agro alimentaire la grande
distribution il faut balayer cette
espèce de triangle des bermudes qui
détruit la crise automnale faut
respecter respecter davantage nos
régions et noté rich cho et je dirais
même nos terroirs
si on veut remettre de l'activité dans
nos territoires il faut que ça passe par
l'agriculture et là sans la
participation de l'europe
il faut faire un don localise à cette
mutation est ce monsieur
le khalife sur guérini un point une
minute il n'a pas une minute dix
certainement pas une milliseconde
vous parliez des cerises mais avec le
c'est à vous allez tomber sous les 40 de
produits toxiques 42 produits toxiques
qui sont interdites sur l'a71
alors on ne peut pas vous raconte lurcy
oui mais c'est tout à fait symbolique du
décalage entre les belles paroles avant
les élections mais vous allez avoir été
minutes vous allez chacun pour des
combats ribout l'ours il va faire du
madame le tirage au sort du début vaut
pour la fin c'est marine le pen qui va
commencer les conclusions vous avez la
parole bien tous ces messieurs qui au
parti socialiste soit l'ump
stanislas guérini représentant les deux
en même temps on construit en réalité
cette europe ultralibérale cette europe
des accords de libre-échange cette
europe de la concurrence déloyale pour
nos agriculteurs pour nos producteurs
cette europe de l'ase l'ouverture totale
des frontières et l'absence totale de
maîtrise de l'immigration ça n'est
évidemment pas auprès d'eux que l'on va
pouvoir aller chercher des solutions
pour demain
les solutions pour demain c est pour
sauver l'europe d'ailleurs c'est de
retrouver la puissance des nations qui
la composent
parce qu'en réalité sans les nations
l'europe n'existe pas c'est tout simple
la technostructure que représente
l'union européenne qui n'était lui par
personne et qui ne défend aucun citoyen
ni aucun peuple
elle ne défend que les intérêts
financiers celle là on n'en veut plus et
les france ont la possibilité de choisir
et c'est vrai qu'on est au devant d'un
gigantesque changement possible
est-ce qu'on sort de l'europe en
tournant le dos à l'union européenne et
est ce qu'on construit une alliance
européenne des nations nous souhaitons
faire avec nos amis le pen avec matteo
salvini en italie avec jetera re on est
avec ceux qui partagent olivier py avant
ces bons est parti socialiste une minute
pour conclure ce débat je suis un
européen convaincu
je pense que c'est en fait la plus belle
histoire que les européens se sont donné
à eux mêmes après la seconde guerre
mondiale et que aujourd'hui c'est la
solution pour nombre de sujets auxquels
nous sommes confrontés les grands défis
on a beaucoup parlé du climat de
l'immigration est effectivement à chaque
fois c'est à ce niveau là que les choses
peuvent
jouer maintenant l'union européenne on
le sait aussi c'est un magma enfin une
zone un peu compliqué ce soir ça a été
évoqué seul le débat ne sera pas au
lendemain du 26 mai entre madame le pen
et monsieur guérini ne le croyez pas
l'un comme l'autre seront extrêmement
minoritaire au parlement européen
le débat il est entre l'europe libérale
courbet hôte monsieur wauquiez
et puis l'europe sociale écologique que
je représente
dans ce débat et moi je souhaite
effectivement une europe qui soit plus
sociale plus écologique qui soit une
europe qui change qui évolue et pour
cela il faut des combattants des gens
qui soient prêts à se battre
je finis simplement d'un mot pour vous
dire que la liste que va conduire à fès
boulemane aujourd'hui elle est composée
de femmes et d'hommes c'est un effort
vous aviez minutes pour conclure la fin
nicolas dupont aignan votre conclusion
comme avant chaque élection européenne
c'est extraordinaire tous ceux qui ont
signé tous les traités se plaignent des
effets de ces traités c'est ça or moi je
ne fais pas confiance à ceux qui ont
créé cette union européenne pour la
changer
il ne l'a changeront jamais la preuve
c'est qu'ils sont prisonniers de ces
traités de leurs partenaires personne
n'a parlé de l'allier de monsieur
bellamy le ppe qui est un parti
fédéraliste personne n'a parlé que les
socialistes et la république en marche
travailleront en fait avec monsieur
juncker ou à sauver avec son successeur
c'est la même chose ils ont exactement
créer la même europe alors en même temps
s'est aperçu aujourd'hui qu'on ne
réglerait les problèmes français que si
on remplaçait cette union européenne par
une europe radicalement différente et
moi si j'ai choisi comme chef de parti
de m'engager et des têtes de listes aux
européennes c'est parce que je suis
convaincu qu'avec le changement qu'il y
a dans tous les pays d'europe
et aujourd'hui on a très peu parlé de
nos partenaires étrangers or c'est avec
les autres peuples qu'on va changer
l'europe et c'est pourquoi je pense
qu'il ya une occasion absolument
historique à strasbourg et à debout la
france nous avons tissé un partenariat
avec 23 parties pour de l'intérieur dire
stop à tous ces traités revoir
complètement l'architecturé de l'union
européenne et ce n'est qu'à cette
condition que tous les maux disco qu'on
aura pu avoir ici
auront un sens sinon une fois là bas ils
revoteront exactement les mêmes choses
et je dis aux français qui m'écoutent
ne vous laissez pas tromper par ceux qui
vous ont trompé à chaque élection
européenne et notamment votre écoute et
d'abord merci et bravo aux
téléspectatrices aux téléspectateurs
11-16 émetteurs qui sont restés jusqu'à
maintenant c'est un moment démocratique
important qu'on est en train de vivre
parce que l'europe et le monde sont un
moment de bascule on le voit bien toutes
les crises s'entremêlent les crises
environnementales les crise sociale et
crise démocratique les crise de
civilisation les crises géopolitiques et
il faut redonner une perspective
politique est encore une fois l'europe
et le périmètre
idéal pour faire ré atterrir la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
quand utilise ce terme d'atterrir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il faut reconstruire une
économie qui est en lien avec la réalité
terrestre
j'ai parlé d'agriculture j'ai parlé de
transition énergétique j'ai parlé tous
ces sujets qui doivent reprendre corps
avec la réalité de nos territoires
j'ai conso si que cette europe elle a
besoin d'être moins technocratique voire
plus du tout technocratique et recréer
un lien non pas avec les états nations
mais avec nos régions avec nos terroirs
nous les écologistes au niveau européen
nous avons des partenaires dans tous les
pays qui sont bien sûr écologistes et
qui sont aussi régionaliste parce que je
crois vraiment pour retrouver ce lien
avec l'europe
j'ai faut arrêter de penser que tout se
fait au niveau uniquement global c'est
aussi par le niveau local qu'on y arrive
et donc partout en europe nous avons le
même projet c'est le plan vert pour la
transition que vous pouvez trouver sur
internet partout et c'est notre feuille
de route pour pouvoir sauver l'europe en
la changeant ouï-dire souffler pour la
radio ce qu'il y a des clés de ce qu'est
ce qu'on attend pour tout changer merci
beaucoup david cormand votre wii ce soir
moi dans ce débat j'ai représenté une
majorité nouvelle
en europe c'est la première fois que
nous nous présentons aux élections
européennes et notre ambition c'est de
faire en sorte que la voix de la france
porte à nouveau en europe que la france
pèse à nouveau dans les institutions
européennes
ce qu'elle avait malheureusement arrêté
de faire depuis trop d'années
c'est pour ça que nous avons fait le
choix de rassembler des personnalités
sur la liste renaissance qui viennent
d'horizons politiques différents qui ont
des parcours
de vie différent mais qui partagent la
même conviction que nous devons avoir
une france plus forte parce que nous
aurons une europe demain plus forte et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on porte
le projet de refondation de l'union
européenne c'est la raison pour laquelle
on a appelé notre liste renaissance
parce que on pense que l'europe elle
doit se recentrer sur les projets
prioritaires elle doit investir dans la
transition écologique
investir dans les compétences des
européens elle doit protéger y compris
physiquement les européens mais ce soir
en conclusion
moi je voudrais passer aux
téléspectateurs et aux auditeurs un
message le 26 mai aller voter quelles
que soient vos convictions tous d'aller
voter parce que on voit que les choix
démocratiques que nous faisons nous le
voyons avec nos voisins britanniques
nous avons peu parlé du break 6 2 ce
soir ça a des conséquences dans la vie
quotidienne des européens
donc ne laissez pas les autres décider
pour vous même nous avons trop besoin de
l'europe
le 26 mai aller voter adrien quatre ans
adrien cattenom à cadenasser c'est
laurent wauquiez qui terminera donc
c'est adrien 4,9 à redon emmanuel macron
et ceux qui l'ont précédé ont mené le
pays dans une impasse et à présent il
est temps d'en sortir
d'importants défis nous font face et
nous pourrons les relever
en poursuivant l'absurde modèle de la
compétition entre tous
cet avenir en commun auquel nous
aspirons n'est pas atteignable dans le
cadre des actuels traités européens qui
interdisent l'harmonisation sociale et
fiscale sont anti écologique
antidémocratique et antisociales le 26
mai prochain
on vote et ce 26 mai ce vote n'est pas
un à côté du mouvement populaire que
nous connaissons actuellement dans le
pays
c'en est une étape est une étape
importante ce sera la première fois que
nous voterons depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron et sa majorité au
pouvoir
alors ne lui fait pas le cadeau de votre
abstention et ne succombez pas aux
sirènes de madame le pen sa roue de
secours empêcher que se rejoue le
deuxième tour pour y entrent macron et
le pen
et pour cela le vote efficace je le
crois c'est celui de la france est
soumise et de sa tête de liste
manon aubry en donnant de la force à
manon aubry et la liste qu'elle emmène
le 26 mai vous en verrez au parlement
européen des députés de combat l'avenir
n'est pas ce qui va arriver
l'avenir c'est ce que nous allons faire
merci à 4
la parole tout est fait dans cette
élection européenne pour nous faire
croire qu'il n'a pas le choix qu on est
prisonniers entre deux visions de
l'europe d'une part dé construire
l'europe celles portées notamment par
madame le pen par nicolas dupont aignan
pour lesquels le break site est un
modèle on voit aujourd'hui le chaos
keynes a conduit l'autre côté la vision
qui est porté par monsieur guérini par
les listes en marche qui consiste juste
à faire toujours plus de l'europe qui
n'a pas marché
plus de fédéralisme plus d'âge ans plus
de bureaucratie plus de nan moi ma
conviction elle est double et c'est
celle que nous portons et
françois-xavier bellamy la première
d'abord c'est que le chemin c'est de
retrouver l'europe que nous aimions
celle qui est l europe des projets
sortir de cette opposition entre soi la
déconstruction soit le fédéralisme vous
avez le choix
mais la deuxième qui est autrement plus
importantes au fond pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait ça vous avez posé une très
belle question qu'est ce que c'est
qu'être français
qu'est ce que c'est qu'être européen
qu'est ce qu'on a comme l'espoir au fond
de nous réaffirmer réaffirmé ce qu'est
notre mode de vie
redonner du souffle à nos valeurs à ce
qu'est l'europe à ce qu'est la france
on a évoqué ce soir bien des menaces qui
pèsent autour de nous la chine les etats
unis l'islamisme l'émigration
quel est notre bataille l'autre bataille
c'est de retrouver nos fondations la
bataille c'est de retrouver cet espoir
de réaffirmer ce que nous sommes ce que
nous sommes c'est à la fois réaffirmé
notre identité française c'est redonner
du souffle à la civilisation européenne
et la conviction que nous partageons
républicain c'est que ça suppose de
retrouver ses fondations
le travail le respect et l'autorité la
transmission de ce qu'est notre culture
c'est ce défi là qui nous attend et
celui là il est autrement plus important
que toutes les discussions parfois
passionnés parfois un peu touffu
parce qu'à l'arrivée ce qui nous
intéresse c'est précisément qu'est ce
qu'on transmet à ceux qui sont derrière
nous c'est cette bataille leur nounou
passion
merci et laurent wauquiez merci à tous
et à toutes merci mathieu belliard pour
ce débat banyuls et un repas tout de
suite débriefer commentaires à suivre
avec sonia mabrouk et ses invités bonne
soirée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous votre soirée spéciale
évidemment se poursuit sur ces news
merci d'être là cette heure tardive
c'est l'heure à présent bien de
l'analyse